we were late
by a few minutes for some reason youtube
would not let us stream and every time
we tried it kept saying
live streaming is not available right
now
and i tried refreshing we tried stopping
the uh
the broadcasting software and turning it
back on nothing worked i think it may
have something to do with the title
which is greta tunberg burned in effigy
gets activists arrested
for sedition with our guest james
o'keefe
and no matter what i did it didn't work
and so i tried i tried something
i changed the title to youtube is giving
us the business and won't let us stream
and all of a sudden
streaming worked so uh it's funny a lot
of people in the chat were saying i
wonder if this is the stream that gets
tim
banned because we're having james
o'keefe on the show and talking about
greta toomberg
for those who don't know the story she
accidentally tweeted out
an activist tool kit and now
activists in india are freaking out
saying she's essentially interfering in
their politics and
burning images of her burning her and
effigy and
we also have james o'keefe because he's
got a story he's breaking about mark
zuckerberg and some leaked videos
so i wonder if the reason the stream
wasn't working because his name was in
the title i guess
i have no idea but it was really strange
because it kept
this overlay would appear that said
livestream is not available and you
could click try again or finish if you
clicked finish
it would take you out of the streaming
studio
and then just put you back in regular
youtube is the weirdest thing
so i i went in i changed the title and
apparently that worked so
um as you already know we we've got we
got a lot of budget
a bunch of different things to talk
about um we are joined today obviously
by
our guest james o'keefe uh james if you
would like to introduce yourself
uh now as you as you may notice james is
a small gorilla
standing on the desk because there's not
actually uh
a james o'keefe in that chair and it's
because
he's late so y'all can blame him but he
should be here in about 10 minutes or so
and uh
james we got to make him do push-ups
when he comes here make a difference
yeah punishment no he's going to take
he's got to take a shot for every five
minutes he was late oh no so he's that
was that one shot
mcgregor stuff don't we yeah yeah that's
pretty good right i never even had a
taste
oh really oh you're weird you don't want
you don't want the polish to drink you
do not it's trouble
they were offering me beers yesterday
i'm like trust me you don't want this
uh if you think youtube's giving you the
business wait until the
person starts drinking i just don't like
booze anyway i don't know i'm not a big
fan yeah
this will be like the first time the
guest is like running in covered in
sweat like i'm here
i'm here let's start asking him really
complex hard questions
just to make it harder on him like as
soon as he gets here yes yes
can you guys give him something why m
equals mc square tell us now
did you guys ever actually that's
actually whatever
you got did you guys ever go through
hard drinking phases
no no i mean when i was uh like late
teens high schooler
yeah i went through a hard one in my
twenties yeah anyway
you never did a lot of beer has fluoride
i'm watching my third eye oh that's
great
just get pure filtered organic hipster
stuff most beer
has a lot of fluoride in there just
saying why why um cause i use regular
tell me that they use the hops
i i forgot exactly why but cause they
don't know about
uh yeah luke you're a conspiracy
theorist some would say that
[Laughter]
so uh luke luke's here yes they are
burning
effigies of greta thumberg in india i
never thought i would get to say that
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name's liquordowski if we are
change.org and
if you like me and want to support my
voluntary efforts you can on we are
change.org forward slash donate there's
many ways you could get involved
what i'm doing ways without even
spending a dime and because of that i'm
still here so thank you very much
i'm also tweeting up and meaning up a
live storm right now on twitter.com
forward slash luke we are change thanks
for following me on there as well
sometimes the titles really make me
laugh um will be like
greta toomberg burn an effigy with by
indians or something whatever it is
with james o'keefe so you're like james
was there too i don't know
yeah like james was the one who was
leading the protest
uh what's up everybody um good to be
back i'll probably maybe turn my mic
down a touch if that's
i think i'm a little coming in hot oh
yeah but i did uh start ian
crossland.net i got it revamped i'm
selling merch on the website including
things like this awesome
oh cool free the code mug that you can
get over there and you can follow me on
my socials over there so it's great to
be back capitalism very
entrepreneurial yeah and uh when when
james
james gets here we'll uh you know we'll
introduce him but for now the gorilla is
doing is standing in for him he's our
guest
you know he's very angry yeah you know i
don't know why he's got scars on his
chest maybe somebody hit him
definitely we also have sour patch let's
press i am here in the corner laughing
at the gorilla and these guys they're
pretty great over here sorry we're
running late
ladies and gentlemen we have an awesome
sponsor today uh thank you so much give
a shout out to virtual shield virtual
private network
service you can go to
surfinginternetsafe.com click the link
in the description below
and you can get access to a 50 off vpn
service virtual shield
they have been they've been with me the
whole time they're my first sponsor and
they're great
a virtual private network basically
provides a simple layer of security for
you while you browse the internet
they make it much harder for bad actors
hackers and even the government
they make it harder for them to spy on
you so the way i describe bits to make
it
just simpler for everybody you know we
all lock our doors and windows we don't
really expect anyone to break in
but you still have that lock that's what
a virtual private network
basically does for you gives you that
very simple layer of security so if you
go to surfing internetsafe.com
you can get 50 off 24 months of online
security from the world's easiest and
fastest vpn for only 59.88
that's actually 77 off they say plus you
get 50 off all add-ons and other great
discounts
on their other plans they're also proud
to announce that this month all
discounts are guaranteed for life that
means
50 off as long as you are a customer
check it out
go to surfinginternetsafe.com link is in
the description below and seriously guys
but when i first started doing all this
virtual show they're the first company
they're like yo dude
you're cool can we sponsor you and there
and it was just like this tiny little
channel and i was like yes and they
really helped
get us all to like get us where we are
today so serious shout out guys
thank you so much surfing
internetsafe.com and don't forget go to
timcast.com and become a member
because we have exclusive podcast
episodes you can't get anywhere else
we did a little jokey introduction of
the our pillow so if you
actually look at the screen you can see
i'm holding up our pillow it's a burlap
sack full of packing peanuts but we had
a very serious half hour discussion with
will chamberlain
talking about why parlor isn't
necessarily the answer in terms of
social media censorship
and we have a bunch of other episodes
talking about alien technology
and we're planning much much more so we
keep saying we're gonna go to the range
we may actually get to do it
because of a really awesome guest coming
up later this week who's going to give
us the full rundown on
crazy guns and it's going to be a lot of
fun and we're hoping to actually get a
chance this time it was like snowing the
past several weekends
so teamcast.com go and check it out and
uh as for now
we are still waiting for him for james
o'keefe who's probably going 120 miles
an hour down the highway
or something yeah drive safe it's snowy
out there i guess
but uh in the meantime let's jump over
to the first story hey i found a little
trick on the website
i wanted to let people know about it if
you click reply on the video to
a comment and then it says it'll pop up
and it'll say logged in
as and it's your what your name if you
click that you can change your avatar
so when you make a comment you have a
little picture next to it cool i love it
right on a little easter egg let's jump
into the first story
greta tunberg effigies burned in delhi
after tweets on farmers protests
celebrity interventions in flame
sentiments in india
as police investigate pro farmer's tool
kit
so basically what happened is a couple
weeks ago greta tunberg
accidentally tweeted out what's called
the toolkit it's it's basically just a
manual explaining
what to say where to say it how to do
all this stuff
a lot of people find this to be
particularly nefarious they call it
well they say it's similar to
astroturfing do you guys know what
astroturfing is i've heard of it
you're familiar i've heard it what is it
so so basically you'll have these big
organizations special interests that
want to get activists to do a thing
and so they'll hire a bunch of people to
show up
and wave signs sometimes it won't be as
direct as saying like we want to pay an
activist
to do this like hardcore astroturfing
the most nefarious would be getting
random people who don't care about the
politics
to waive a sign but typically what it is
they'll put up
an ad saying like hey do you care about
climate change well then come on down
and protest and you'll get your food and
travel
paid for and essentially those funds
being provided to activists
allows them the ability to be there it's
considered
inorganic right yeah so when you have
greta toomberg putting out this tool kit
where it's basically telling people what
to say
or how to say it how to protect yourself
and things like that a lot of people
view that as nefarious so now you have
well greta tunberg leaked this they say
this from the guardian
tuna became became embroiled in
allegations of an international
criminal conspiracy against india after
she tweeted a toolkit for people who
wanted to show support for the farmer so
there's a big pharma products going on
right now
the document included campaigning tips
such as suggested hashtags and advice on
how to sign petitions
though not named in the police case that
was filed toonberg's tweet
was said to have brought the delhi
police's attention to the existence of
the toolkit
leaders in the ruling bharatiya janata
party
said the toolkit was evidence of
international plans
for attacks against india now i'm just
going to say this because i know a lot
of people are like whoa greta tuneburg
is caught she's astroturfing
i don't think it's that big of a deal
like if if you
say like hey here's the message we're
using here's the hashtags we're using
and you're telling someone how to get
active
i don't think that's that big of a deal
but i do think it's interesting the way
delhi is handling it they're basically
saying
international you know foreign
celebrities interfering in our politics
ain't gonna have none of that so greta
tunberg they're just burning images of
of her and effigy but here's here's
actually the the the big news
not this one it's the next one indian
activist arrested
for creating protest toolkit shared by
greta tunberg
this is this is a huge huge screw-up on
greta's part look
how old is she now greta toomberg
i'm not i don't i don't want to uh you
know drag her too heavily
because she's inexperienced and naive
but this was such a
serious failure of operational security
this woman
is facing i think she's facing like life
in prison let's check out the story they
say
desho ravi 22 could face up to life in
prison
following her arrest sunday in
connection to the online document
which calls for organized support for
india's deadly farmers protests
ravi a leader of the indian arm of
tunburg's fridays for future protest
movement
is being investigated for possible
sedition a charge that carries a penalty
of life imprisonment
a police source told reuters well you
know look
i just heard a lot from democrats about
the dangers of insurrection and sedition
and you know they say these people
should be locked up so uh
what's the difference what's what's that
what's the difference in this story it
sounds like a precedent was set over
here in the u.s and now other countries
are going to take that
and make it totalitarian that's
dangerous that's what they do yeah
often when we see this happen in the u.s
something happened in the u.s other
countries go okay then we can do it too
right
and so that's actually criticism that
was levied at donald trump they were
saying that when he was going after the
press all of a sudden a bunch of other
world leaders started going after the
press too
i think that's kind of silly you know
criticize people if they do something
wrong
trump expressing his opinions on the
media i don't whatever people have
opinions on the media in other countries
like turkey where they're arresting
generals
the guy i was thinking of erdogan
erdogan that's that's turkey arrests
more journalists than anybody else
so here so for those that aren't
familiar what's going on in india i i
just did a quick run through uh
earlier it it's really complicated
complicated i don't know too much but
it's basically
a bunch of farmers have this system
where
it's they have like guaranteed pricing
from the government on the crops they
grow
so it sustains them and there's a
there's new laws that are coming in
that'll basically take that away
and so they're protesting and this makes
a lot of sense as to why the left is
getting involved and saying
support the farmers because the farmers
want a guaranteed minimum government
intervention
over the work they're doing and the new
laws would be more i guess capitalist
according to cnn they'd be allowed to
sell whatever they grow to whoever
wants that whereas right now the
government guarantees a set minimum
price
and only certain people are allowed to
bid on these crops
the deregu i guess you can call it
deregulation it's resulting in these
massive deadly protests
greta tunber gets involved for what
reason i don't really know
now you've got some woman who's facing
uh life in prison
well i don't think anyone should ever be
arrested for posting
anything online especially when it comes
to activist toolkits but
when you look at the larger kind of
international efforts especially by
massively funded pr campaigns there's a
lot of ties between
intelligence agencies and also the
supposed popular uprisings that usually
work in the benefit of american
geopolitics like we saw in ukraine
syria and libya that were very organized
that did have talking points hashtags
and also the coordination of the media
that pushed for a certain agenda and was
able to get it because of these larger
disinformation efforts
and if you study things like the
economic hitman you see these efforts
professions of an economic
yeah confessions of an economic hit man
great book definitely recommend you read
it i read it in high school it changed
my vision of the world
when you look at the kind of ways that
they push for
under rest in order to get to their way
it really makes you think
what's really going on here and we have
seen a lot of pressure
uh on india by individuals like bill
gates that are criticizing india
also just recently they're manufacturing
plants so you know there is
there's something to wonder here about
what's happening on the global scale
whether it's a conspiracy or not we do
not know
but i i still think it's overreaction
for india to arrest a person for for
sharing this
and it's only going to hurt them in the
long run i was in india before i got
some wild stories there
i actually landed in india when they did
a currency reset and the whole country
went in panic
uh yes pete there was riots there was
people dying there's there's
massive civil unrest isn't that isn't
that crazy that some guy can be like oh
that that currency we have
it's now a different currency and
everyone just believes it everything in
india is pretty much cash
uh except for some places in delhi and
when i was in delhi it was fine i went
to goa
everything's in cash which was
absolutely absurd during a currency
reset
where people were sleeping outside of
atms that was tourists
they had it was also weird to see atms
segregated for
local indians and tourists and the
tourists were literally sleeping outside
the indians lines were even
way longer because people didn't have
any money didn't have any cash
oh because they raised the currency
difference they got rid of a
large swap of currency because the
government wanted all the accounting
because a lot of people because it's
such a cash driven
country a lot of people have their money
figure regularly underneath the mattress
the government was like you're not
paying taxes on that so we're just going
to make all of these bills illegal
you're going to have to give them to us
so we could see exactly how much you
have
so we could get you the accurate amount
of money that you owe the government
uh crazy time during the currency
and then crazy story but we got we got
to keep it on i
know but one thing that that kind of
reverted to uh
in india that was very interesting was
people literally doing an honor system
you go to the store you just tell them
your name
you just take down your name you would
have to come back later pay cash but but
a lot of civil unrest happens in in
india uh
the country geopolitically is at a very
important place especially countering
china
so there's a lot of interest in india
they're stabilizing india right now with
china
china is basically on on the border of
india and they're fighting right well
they're having these weird clashes
without any weapons
like clubs but they're using archaic
weapons like
like clubs and sticks and nails and
barbed wire on baseball bats literally
of what they're using fighting each
other
because they have this weird peace
treaty where they can't use
firearms against each other and they
can't use live ammunition against each
other
but they could beat the crap out of each
other which they do but
i've heard recently within the last few
days they actually
uh settled previous conflicts that were
arising just
two weeks ago and they're at a stalemate
now so they're at a position where
there's more peace now than
there was just two weeks ago here's
here's the crazy thing about the toolkit
that gets released
you have to ask yourself who makes these
things who spends the time to develop
an activist guide for protesting and you
mentioned this
luke you've got intelligence agencies
you think about what's going on with
with china and india and the conflict on
the border plus i mean you have
like what pakistan like kashmir all that
stuff
so there's there's good reason for any
adversary of india or us
to create that conflict so when you have
international interests
spreading information that can
destabilize a country
what did the united states say about it
when we had what was it like
a handful of facebook pages with almost
no followers
created by russia yeah they went for
years claiming russia was trying to take
over the country and destabilize
everything and they were freaking out
in fact they're still freaking out
they're foaming at the mouth like
over over some facebook pages now what
would happen if russia was disseminating
pamphlets booklets toolkits
telling people how to bypass arrest how
to win in the legal system
how to protest how to hashtag how to
spread the ideology and when
they would have gone even crazier it
would be it would
if if you think it was nuts now with
with russiagate imagine if russia
actually put together
a toolkit telling people how to do these
things it didn't get that bad
and they still went insane that's what's
happening in india
and greta tunberg is facilitating it and
she's not indian
look if if you are an american if you
are an indian and you put together an
activist guide because you want to help
people and you believe in your cause
well that's cool yeah aoc did that if
you're a foreign
actor of high profile with tons of money
and massive backing from special
interests
and then you are pushing out ideological
and and tactical information that can
exacerbate riots and protests well now
you got a problem
you got a serious problem because what
happens if india actually becomes
destabilized
i i wonder if you know look i kind of
feel bad for greta toomberg because
she's just a kid
the things she's called for in terms of
abandoning fossil fuels outright banning
fossil fuels in the next year or
whatever
not even the issue like now we want it
now it'd just kill millions of people
look at what's happening in texas with
these windmills freezing and the gas
lines freezing
we need to make sure we get the
electricity running already
we can see what happens when you do not
have
the sufficient electrical uh you know
equipment
weathering etc i know a lot of people
are blaming the wind turbines for
freezing but everything basically froze
nobody thought was gonna happen
15 states are having power outages
there's 4.4 million people that went
without power in texas the national
guard had to be deployed right
and there's a huge argument now
happening whether it's the the kind of
free energy or whether it's the
fuels that are you know right right
right right but but just
the basic point with granite timber i'm
trying to make is she doesn't understand
the things she's advocating for
are going to kill millions from getting
rid of the fossil fuels fine
but if look if if riots protests and you
know mass protests
massive unrest sweeps india because the
people of india are challenging their
their legal system
oh okay then you know we want to make
sure people stay safe we don't want a
collapse that results in mass death we
want reform we want people to
you know do the right thing and we don't
want fighting in the streets
gratitude doesn't understand what
destabilization or collapse really means
and i don't think she
i don't think i mean i guess she would
care if she knew but i don't think she
knows
i don't think she realizes what it means
for someone of her profile
to be having these conversations
apparently there are like some leaked
messages as well
where she's saying like oh these hate
campaigns they happen
it's like dude the hate campaigns are
happening because you're interfering in
a foreign country's politics
and you have massive clout that's
getting tons of attention
and spreading this artificial you know
external ideology
inside the country so surprised people
are protesting her
these are they're calling it an
international criminal conspiracy man
yeah a lot of eyes are on india and i
think we're going to be hearing about
india a lot more especially in the near
future
especially with their very strategic
very important position in the world
because
as as the china is going to be expanding
their influence they're going to also be
propping up
pakistan these are all nuclear powers
and when you look at
india i mean they have a vast emerging
middle class
that speaks english that is ready to
help even even by some estimates even by
some experts
be the next hegemonic world power even
over
china because they they are in a better
position than china on the world map
uh comparatively as well so so india is
going to be a very key crucial place to
to sway your influence in especially in
the not so distant future
and uh it's not a surprise that this is
happening to me in my opinion i got
mixed feelings about
uh what what this is all about this
farmer protest now what i'm trying i'm
trying to figure it out too so maybe we
can clarify it
sounds like what they're doing is right
now
uh if if a big multi-national
multi-corporate
uh farming industry in india wanted to
sell
bare bottom prices and out and outmatch
all the the local farmers they could
sell their
their corn for three dollars and the
government would have to step in
tim is this is this can you clarify this
i don't know a whole lot okay so what
what they want to
the government would would subsidize it
but it's basically right now government
regulated sales versus
absolute free markets so like the
general if monsanto wanted to sell three
dollar corn and
the the farmer was like i can't afford
to sell my corn for three dollars or put
me out of business okay
the government would say okay you can
sell your coin for ten dollars we'll
subsidize seven of it and then it'll go
three dollars to the market
no maybe that sounds like maybe what is
going on right now but they want to
change it so that
government gets out of the way and
corporates can sell whatever but the
danger is
the gist of what we monsanto could
undercut these locals we don't know that
this is what it sounds like they're
probably sure sure we don't know that we
don't
we don't know that we don't know that we
don't know exactly the limits of this
law it's a foreign country and i can't
tell you
i can only tell you that cnn said right
now the current system is a government
minimum guarantee for crops versus a
sell to anyone at any price model right
with the sell to anyone model is
could be dangerous because if you have
monsanto over there and they want to
sell three dollar corn and
the local farmers can't afford it it'll
bankrupt local farmers
so that's why government is in there to
help subsidize local farmers
um and and it's never this simple and we
just don't know
it and ultimately maybe it doesn't even
matter what it is it's just that there's
foreign nationals
in flint but i mean that's that's the
name of the game right now the globe is
connected you know
where it's it's not even a national
national game it's the same thing with
china bro
it's it's it's not that america wants
cheaper products made in china
they don't the american people want jobs
they want to be able to work they want
to feel fulfilled
i find it hilarious that we have so many
gen z memes
where it's like there was one where it's
from the incredibles where you know
have you guys seen the incredibles the
family of superheroes yeah so basically
like
superheroes are outlawed and then like
this mr incredible is now an insurance
you know adjuster or whatever and it
said like me there's like a meme it's
like me working in an office
you know getting paid for you know for
an unfulfilling existence or something
and i'm like yeah people want meaningful
jobs they want to make things to be
proud of
but all of those are being shipped away
so these jobs are going to china
why because billionaires because the
billionaires
and the millionaires in this country
that's why now bernie sanders you know
mock him essentially because he's no
longer fighting against the millionaires
and the billionaires
but same thing with you you mentioned
these these companies the international
ties
regular people don't want this stuff
they just want to be with their families
they want to make enough they want to
get by they want to survive
they don't want to boot on their neck
from the government and they don't want
their
their jobs being sent overseas oh my
look who's late you are 27 minutes late
nice jacket that's five shots of whiskey
we want 27 push-ups
immediately hold on so we're going to
frame you up here
uh and ian surprisingly also very
interestingly
uh india's supreme court just a few
years ago ruled
that uh monsanto seeds couldn't be
in the country so there's there's you
know a lot of interesting news
surrounding india especially a lot of
media figures now
saying that they're very surprised that
uh india dealt with the coronavirus a
lot better than any other country but of
course that's not a surprise to us
especially after talking to chris
martinson in peak prosperity
why they did so well you could see our
conversations i did a video with him tim
did a video with him
but ladies and gentlemen yeah james
finally
out what up dog i had to charter a plane
oh my god tell us about that so glad
you're here location
doing some gorilla yes gorilla
get the mic like direct right straight
in two bit and maybe i don't
turn how are you doing dude how was your
journey
it's been crazy a crazy day we just
broke a story on mark zuckerberg oh ceo
facebook tell us more
on uh covertly recorded taking an
anti-vaccine stance
in violation of his own policy at
facebook so
uh that's very interesting and a lot to
talk about there tim well let's uh
you want to talk about it you want to
tell us why you to charter a plane or
what's going on
i can't if i told you i'd have to kill
you okay i don't know
um just been a crazy 24 hours and i i
apologize i'm late but uh i have good
guys oh it is what it is
i was getting text messages i'm like
we're doing the show we put the gorilla
in your in your place yeah
gorilla journal's entertaining that's
right he was doing all right he wasn't
saying a whole lot but you know he looks
angry so
he's definitely you know rounds people
up there all right what's up headphones
i think you got them
oh yeah yeah yeah see normally this is
the stuff we do before
the show dude what is up with project
veritas punctuality is not my strength
now we know yeah so what's going on man
welcome to the show thanks for having me
tim i appreciate it
yeah yeah so just well give us the
latest then like we can talk about the
the
the
the
just broke a story as i'm getting here
this is the ceo facebook mark zuckerberg
we just broke it i broke it on twitter
i'm still i'm back on twitter project
veritas has been permanently suspended
before you get started i have to tell
you what happened to us when we tried to
start this show
okay so the the story we led with is
about you know greta tunberg i don't
know if you heard the news
she shared this activist toolkit and now
protesters are burning her effigy
because she they view her as an
international entity who's
fueling these these deadly protests that
are happening in india
so the title of the video was greta
tunberg burned in effigy
and uh uh activist is charged with
sedition
with james o'keefe the first thing that
happened was when we clicked create
stream
it said we weren't allowed to do it like
an error occurred or something
and so we had to go back and recreate so
so for those that aren't familiar
you have to like you click start a
stream and then it gives you the title
all the
timing and everything we fill out the
forms we click to go and then it worked
and we're like okay
finally that's awesome we go in i start
i click
streaming on the broadcast software and
then all of a sudden youtube says live
streaming is not available right now
so i refresh try again refresh try again
turn the
software off turn it back on none of it
works
but i took i took the title and changed
it to
youtube is giving us the business won't
let us stream worked oh that's that's
that's interesting
the funny thing is people were
commenting is this the episode's going
to get tim band having james o'keefe on
right now
and i took a picture i i tweeted the
image i am not i am not exaggerating i
tweeted out the images live streaming is
not available
when i changed the title which removed
your name and greta toonberg's i don't
know what caused it maybe it was burned
in effigy maybe it was edition i have no
idea
it's working now now it's working well
i'm on the show so
i don't know if i mean our youtube is
still this is a youtube right yes
youtube streaming so they haven't banned
us on youtube but a lot to unpack here a
lot to talk about
i'll let you be the captain and you know
tell us how well you want me to go
i think that was uh uh look you were
late but we were also several minutes
late as well because we couldn't get the
strength to get the stream going and i
just want to stress
as soon as you know greta tuneburg james
o'keefe the title was changed it worked
don't ask me why it's not the first time
something you know
i was joking with with my colleague my
colleagues who are standing over there
the entourage the project veritas
entourage
all flow on a private line yeah it was
it was a crazy day you wouldn't even
believe it if i told you
you'll know some soon i was saying that
whoever these
people in san francisco or wherever they
are like you know
shadow boosting banning censoring
they're worried
because they're thinking there might be
a whistleblower who's over watching this
who might record us banning and
censoring so maybe they're deterred from
doing it
too like the psychological deterrent
effect so we just broke a story mark
zuckerberg on the hidden camera or he's
covertly recorded on one of his staff
goals
taking this this this anti-covet vaccine
stance in violation of facebook's
own policies zuckerberg says uh my
understanding this is a quote from
zuckerberg now not me
my understanding is that these vaccines
modify
dna and rna now facebook has a policy
implemented
recently you're not allowed to say that
so i was thinking
would be me quoting zuckerberg playing
the videotape of mark zuckerberg
get banned on facebook because it's in
violation of facebook's own policy it
probably would
well they'll try so right we had uh you
guys know jack murphy
we had jack murphy on the show he said
on this show he was like
donald trump gave i'm not even going to
quote what jack said because
they've come after us for it he
basically said donald trump's
jack murphy said that donald trump said
something about voter fraud
and they used that and accused us as a
show of making those claims
when we've we've not we've actually
argued against them we've
been we've even had some prominent trump
supporters give a more
like balanced approach to what's going
on with the whole election stuff and
they tried accusing us of being
conspiracy theorists for simply saying
trump said a thing
so you quoting zuckerberg they're going
to claim they're going to claim james
o'keefe
pushed the conspiracy theory
and they won't tell people push the i
mean the anti-vaccine conspiracy theory
right
but i'm literally quote i'm i'm so what
i my headline on the story was facebook
ceo mark zuckerberg takes anti-vaccine
stance in violation of his own
platform's policy
so and it'd be funny to see if we get a
comment from is it andy stone
spokesperson to facebook has he
responded yet no so we have emailed him
we've
we've
carrier pigeoned him we do everything
text what
text him called him um but tim you know
the
facebo uh twitter has permanently
suspended project veritas twitter
account
the official comment that twitter gave
cnn
uh reporter brian fung of cnn business
is they said that we have uh published
people's private information twitter did
not say
that i misinformation or fake news no no
they said the reason that we were
suspended is because we're doxing people
project veritas is publishing people's
private information
the evidence of that was us doing a
routine tv doorstop that is to say
you know television reporters go outside
someone you know someone's driveway cnn
does it all the time like they do
the memers didn't cnn do that with that
old woman yes
thank you yes and that tweet and you
could actually see the numbers on her
on her house so it doesn't it's
completely illogical
because i mean but that's their
censoring
but but but here's the interesting part
and i have the documents in front of me
because i want to get
my facts correct brian fung of cnn says
that we
were repeated violation of the company's
quote anti-doxing policies
but then but then just sunday uh the
host's name was
anna cabrera was on with brian stelter
and she said that project veritas was
removed from misinformation so cnn's own
reporters are contradicting each other
they're just making stuff up
so what you're saying is you're gonna
get a retracto out of this i'm we have
we our lawyer
has sent a letter to cnn corporate uh
david vigilante is the general counsel
of cnn and we are going to get a
retractor
retracto the correction alpaca he's
coming at you
it sounds like it wasn't so much that
you guys got busted for doxing but that
it was the who you were doxing because
wasn't it somebody that was high profile
so this is a little nuanced but i think
it's important that we take your
audience through the facts because i
think it's important because i think
twitter has crossed a rubicon here that
they have not
previously crossed i mean look at the
hunter biden stuff man they suppressed a
very relevant news story to help someone
win
a presidential presidential election
that is true i mean these people are
evil man that is true so what happened
here was
uh we i don't know if you've ever
experienced this but
when you are flagged twitter gave us the
option it said
uh you can simply get your account
reinstated at project veritas by
deleting this tweet
they want us to delete the tweet the
video of my reporter christian hartsock
with a camera and a flag mic you could
see the flag mic there's no hidden
camera recording here
in in a street on a sidewalk outside the
house of
facebook vice president was this public
property what was his name
guy rosen was this public property this
was a public street a residential street
and his residence and we're following
the lead of cnn
cnn goes and door stops people local tv
news so i so christian hartsock asks guy
rosen for comment
uh on a this is maybe the biggest public
policy story of our of our lives
we're not confronting a private citizen
we're con he's a private he's vice
president of facebook
and then twitter says you need to take
down this video clip
off twitter but i decided i'm not going
to do that tim
i would be against my conscience i'm
going to appeal it i knew it was a risk
and usually when you appeal that takes a
week or two to do and then
in the middle of the day twitter got
bombarded with phone calls by the new
york times
cnn and everyone else and twitter
changed their minds it said nope we've
changed our mind we're now going to ban
project veritas forever
permanently suspended for some reason my
personal account was reinstated
it doesn't make any sense because both
me and project veritas tweet the same
stuff
pressure that's just media it's it's
this is what the the game is for these
uh i want to call them journalists these
are activists
because i i broke a story i think it was
a year and a half ago
where someone someone who worked at a
major bank
leaked to me internal documents about
i think we actually uh uh i think we may
have talked about this after the fact
yeah
um they leaked me these documents and it
was basically showing that
this bank had banned the uh well i got
to be very careful here
it appeared to be that certain
right-wing individuals had their
accounts closed
because an email from a journalist said
why are you supporting white supremacy
or something to that effect
so what they do is a real journalist is
going to email someone and say
you know a story came out and you know
actually i i got to say this there's
literally no news in
finding out that someone has a bank
account and then emailing the bank and
saying why does this person have a bank
account right
we know why people have bank accounts
what they do is they contact the bank
they the email then says something like
this individual
has been accused of being a white
supremacist why do you
support white supremacy the bank gets
the message it's mafioso they're
basically saying
we are going to write a story claiming
you support white supremacist
organizations
and then the bank says oh we don't we we
banned those people and then the
activists pretending to be journalists
go ah
okay great getting financial
institutions or other companies to
destroy their enemies
so it's not too dissimilar you uh james
are one of the i think veritas is one of
the very few
actual news organizations i i look i
think
there's a lot of news outlets and a lot
of good journalists and they work hard
and they do well
but you look at how awful things have
gotten with these major corporate news
outlets
there's no risk to the establishment to
the corporate uh powers to the special
interests
from cnn or the new york times right i
mean very little
yeah but but it's like you were saying
these people
are looking over their shoulders not
knowing who is going to hold them
accountable
by either recording their unethical
behaviors
and exposing them doing wrong they don't
know who that's going to be and so
they're worried about it and they're
worried about you
getting rid of you will make their lives
very i think there's a psychological
like i say right now as i speak if there
are coders engineers wherever they may
be silicon valley
when they do their whatever they do
that's unethical or at least dishonest i
know they're private companies they can
do whatever they want constitutionally
but
there's that little thought inside their
head like the jury on your shoulder
sort of worried deterred maybe maybe
someone's observing me do this thing
but what's most interesting about this
situation that where project veritas was
permanently suspended was
twitter changed their mind tim just as
you said once they got bombarded with
all that pressure from new york times
and cnn being like what's the deal
are they suspended permanently or not
and someone high up at twitter said
nope we're going to suspend them forever
and that shows me that the washington
post and the new york times
and and cnn actually have tremendous
power and jeff bezos
who is whatever he is a trillionaire
billionaire trillion dollar market cap
one of the wealthiest men in the history
of the world is most proud
of his ownership of that woke click bait
rag washington post
that's his crowning achievement in life
so i
i actually am not one of those people
who say these
these companies cnn has tremendous power
to get twitter to change their mind by
making a phone call
think about it cnn spreads baseless
theories
they they eat human brains they dox
people they even had an article not so
long ago that was titled quote how cnn
found the reddit user behind the trump
wrestling
gif yep where they what's the date on
that one what's the date on that one
uh july 5th 2017. wow where they
knowingly
went after someone because of that
famous gift that
donald trump tweeted and they said
publicly apologize right now or we're
going to
doxx they said promise never to do it
again exactly otherwise we'll release
your privacy
and this is the organization that's
spearheading this censorship movement
that never gets called out for their
baseless theories for their fake news in
their lives even the new york times
yesterday we were talking about a
specific story
where the new york times was caught
fabricating the story
about the fire extinguisher killing and
and and beating to death
or or as a capital police officer at the
very least getting burned by their
sources
and refusing to correct until a month
later exactly and then now today
they also have another article that's
titled unfettered conversations are
taking place
on clubhouse talking about how it's
dangerous this new kind of platform
that's rising in popularity because
they don't know how to deal with
harassment misinformation and quote
privacy can can i point out the the
beautiful irony
of was it anna cabrera i think you said
was that was anna cabrera
saying that you were suspended
permanently for misinformation
and that statement itself is
misinformation i mean i have the two
fire trucks by the way we were going to
get our lawyer
we could always just sue cnn we see the
new york times we'll talk about that in
a minute but
that i've got two statements from cnn in
front of me right now one is from
brian fung cnn business who's actually a
pretty nice yeah i think he's a serious
reporter
and he says that veritas was suspended
for quote
threats of sharing other people's
private information i have a way threats
this is threats of sharing other
people's private information
literally what cnn did luke just cited
that story from them and then i have a
statement from anna cabrera this is on
the air with brian stelter on sunday
quote twitter has suspended the account
of project veritas
i'm quoting her now so forgive it's not
my words forgive me
quote a conservative actionist a
activist organization at least that's
how they
they couch themselves i have never in my
life
referred to myself as a conservative
activist not once i was swear to it
under oath in a defamation lawsuit
against cnn
unless they retract that and then she
goes on quote this is a much broader
crackdown by social giants on accounts
promoting misinformation
so our general counsel has just sent a
letter to
david vigilante today i have the letter
in front of me signed
a failure to retract will sue by the way
these
organizations are used to throwing the
spear at
uh civilian innocent people they're not
used to being the spear being thrown at
them
i've sued the new york times for
defamation in in the new york supreme
court and we're going to get past motion
to dismiss
in a in a lawsuit we talked about this
last time you and i talked about this
we need to sue the [ __ ] out of them and
and
and i'm not doing it to harass i'm doing
it because that's justice if you lie if
you intentionally
disregard the truth that's called actual
malice i'm a public figure
you can't under the law of new york
state
intentionally lie we'll get past motion
to dismiss
and then you get into depositions that
means i put dean baquet
executive editor of the new york times
in a chair and he's required by the law
to answer my questions under oath
not only that but isn't there an
opportunity for discovery maybe get
access to discovery
depositions interrogatories they are
required
to answer my questions when i confront
dean beckham the street in los angeles
that's the executive editor of the new
york times
he just ran away and laughed maniacally
but when the judge
says no you're you are you have to
answer project veritas's questions why
did you intentionally lie about james
o'keefe
we have so many lawsuits tim that
that our lawyer i just think we're going
to start suing people
i think it's time and because you can't
you can't defame
people and get away with it anymore so
long as people don't fight back
you can but not seems like they picked a
fight they're not you know
it's really expensive the problem with
litigation is that
each of these lawsuits is a million
bucks but we talked about this last time
remember we said someone should start a
non-profit and just start suing people
yes
who lie well that that might actually
just be project
you know one-third of our budget at this
point you know you'll make money on it
yeah the people's defamation defense
fund right exactly
perfect just get a big fund and then
track when you know the issue is there
are a lot of people now who are finding
themselves in the public sphere
who have small careers as personalities
pundits and journalists
they can't go up against the new york
times small individual
maybe there's a journalist who's got
seventy thousand twitter followers and
they're making
you know 30 to 50k a year off of being
an independent journalist well tim do
you think it's affordable
do you think it's psychologically two
people want to be liked by the new york
times or want their book reviewed is it
that oh
psychological effect they don't want to
take on an institution as as revered
as beloved what do you think about it do
you ever wonder i was reading something
that was really interesting they talk
about how
the old mythological stories of heroism
were individuals challenging the system
fighting against the gods and the
superheroes of today
are supporting the system and fighting
on behalf of the establishment
so i wondered about that you have people
right now that don't want to
challenge the machine no matter how evil
or wrong it may be no matter how much
they oppress
and harm the working class the little
guy the individual
they want to be a part of the machine
they want to be the one hazing the other
person not the one getting hazed so when
you look at the
the the unfettered power the new york
times where cnn has
to destroy lives why would anyone choose
to be on the other end of that
so i mean it's a legitimate and i think
the same
psychological effect has on people i've
noticed that since
project veritas has been banned i don't
want to share project
because i'm id band i want people to
draw an analogy that's like saying i
don't want to tell the truth because the
new york times might be mean to me
okay let's treat twitter like the new
york times don't draw a distinction
between big tech and big media they are
one and the same in fact the algorithms
prefer cnn right
well youtube creates a special section
on their front page for
carousel the establishment news outlets
you're not going to find
well you may get recommended shows like
this you may get recommended my other
channels which is
news commentary and journalism but cnn
gets special privilege
and what's funny is download vid iq i
love this plugin i use it
and it shows you a percentage next to
the title of every video video of the
thumbs up to thumbs down ratio
you'll see the recommended videos are
usually overwhelmingly
thumbs up well they're being recommended
it'll be videos from maybe me or steven
crowder or maybe people like kyle
kalinsky depending on your politics or
jimmy dore
but then you'll see this special
mainstream media carousel and it's all
ten percent thumbs up five percent just
overwhelmingly rejected by the users of
youtube
but youtube desperate for the the
approval of cnn the new york times abc
etc drop
to their knees and beg cnn to like them
beg
yep i think it's uh fair to say as you
were mentioning james there that the
mainstream media and social media
companies definitely share the same
activist toolkits as some people would
say
uh but this is interesting i think this
is the bigger story here the legal
aspect of it because if you remember not
so long ago cnn had to settle with the
covington
kids yes so there is a president
underscore this undisclosed we don't
know exactly how much but if if that's
the case that we don't know how much
that means it's
it's it's a good much it's a lot not
necessarily but
i do want to address that so i see a lot
from the left
saying this was clearly a nuisance fee
they probably paid the bare minimum just
to make them go away i don't think
that's true
that's ironic i don't think that's true
though i don't because
uh i believe the the motion dismiss
failed
and they were potentially looking at
depositions and discovery right that
sounds to me
like the covington kids and their lawyer
probably said we don't need a nuisance
fee we can put more pressure on you
cnn probably they definitely didn't pay
250 million dollars to settle
but it probably was uh nice it's hard to
know that was the lawyer
in that lynn wood was the attorney for
that crazy but it's also the washington
post that's settled
so it's not just scenes it's a number i
think tim you're right
what they fear most and i've been
through 12 of these depositions i don't
know if you guys have been sued i've
been sued so many times
and i've won we project verdas has never
lost a lawsuit i always talk about that
we've never
lost a lawsuit never settled a lawsuit
so they fear me they they fear
litigation and the reason they fear it
is the reason you said
discovery when you people don't
understand depositions they get all
the emails they've looked at all my
emails that's why i'm so clean i've
never broken the law
at project veritas we're so clean
because they look at
all of our emails that can't find
anything but what happens when you open
up cnn's emails tim
when you get when you get uh brian
stelter anna cabrera
and and and brian fung in a deposition
chair under oath so
cabrera says one thing they're going to
be they're going to be attacking each
other
yes their lawyer is going to be like how
do we solve this one
and you can't purge yourself in federal
court you can't contradict yourself so
i actually came to this epiphany in the
last week or two we just need to start
we just need to start suing the [ __ ] out
of them uh when you have a case when you
have a case for defamation
that pre that when you get past motion
to dismiss that's when people start
settling lawsuits
and uh you're not going to settle though
are you i don't think so i mean i
i've never settled on defense on offense
i mean it's going to cost me
over a million dollars to get to a jury
verdict in the new york times litigation
that's a lot of money
plus you have to consider i think that
judges and oftentimes in these cases
will accept apologies and retractions
too
if they were if the new york times
retracted the this is the i talked to
you about this last time this was the
minnesota video and
ilhan omar in the new york times said i
was part of a coordinated
disinformation campaign the new york
times said that because they cited some
idiot professor in some random place
just saying i think james is part of a
coordinated information campaign
and then they and then they cross cited
that on usa today
and then facebook cited usa today and
then banned our video so
i i i if they offered money i'd consider
it but
um i think my conscience says i'm going
to go all the way to a jury verdict yeah
i would also ask for an apology and for
cnn to eat more human brains on national
television
we will never you know pass over an
opportunity to mention that a cnn host
on tv eight human brain and it's still
on youtube right now
on numerous channels recommended and
promoted
alternative independent media gets
screwed over because the mainstream
media giants
always get promoted in the algorithms no
matter what and and
they get caught so many times with their
pants down lying to the american public
whether through their sources whether or
not knowingly or normally we don't know
until
watching this discovery the people
watching this and
obviously every comment i see is what
are you going to do about it i mean
people are just
tired of complaining so i think a
solution this is a solution
we sue them okay because i can't tell
you how many i have
a dozen cases i'm i'm you know trying to
be the change i wish to see in the world
as gandhi said i'm doing it we're suing
the new york times for defamation
in new york supreme court we will get
past motion to dismiss and tim
there's a very strong chance the new
york times tries to settle
and give me money you you need to do a
like remix remastered orchestral
retracto
with like no we're bringing in live
promise
we're bringing alpacas let's go to india
we're going to get an alpaca farm
yes an actual llama i insist so by the
way i didn't this was like a dumb
idea came up andrew breitbart came up
with this 10 years ago people actually
their favorite videos are the
retractable videos it's a good song
i think they love the fact that we
actually get them to admit that they're
lying
you know it's pretty cool but the
question do you think that i should take
the money or go all the way to a jury
verdict i think we should do if i could
recommend something
is you cover your costs but then you
take the the money out of it and you
create it and you put it in this fund
where you can protect the other nation
the people's what do you call it the
people's defamation defense yeah
when you protect that when you protect
the redditors and the memers that cnn
keeps going after or the grandma that
they door stopped
right you help those individuals in a
fund after recouping some of your
initial costs
you take that's what you take the uh the
dividends and you you
uh you start a fund with that well so
the one thing i would say is just
you know weigh the risks if the new york
times comes to you and offers
apology retraction and settlement and
you say no the judge might tell you to
screw off
he might be like what do you mean you
won they came to you and they said
they're gonna give you everything you
want
so it may it may be great to get a jury
victory that's only if they they fight
you all the way
i gotta say we we covered this story the
other day a couple times you know as the
story has been emerging
the the officer in the capital riots new
york times put out fake information
the next day and i missed this this is
because i trust the new york times
it was reported in houston the officer
died of an unrelated stroke
the new york times didn't change the
article until a month and
a week or so later so i don't think the
new york times
is they're going to resist i think
they're going to resist as much as
possible
any kind of admit admitting fault but
i'll tell you this man if you get the
new york times
to you know issue a full retraction
apology they've done that before for you
haven't that's a that's a win yes we've
got
we have we have hundreds of attractions
and corrections including a couple from
the new york times
if they if they offer to retract the
article and apologize to me that's
there's that that's
that's that's the case we win that's
what i wanted in the first place but
they tim they refused
to do that right and um i think they
didn't
i think i called their bluff i think
they're like oh you know screw you and
they're not
they're not used to people fighting back
they're not
they're used to railroading people and
the biggest epiphany for me was
because we got raw story to retract an
entire paragraph i don't know if you've
heard of raw story
yeah of course of course woke click bait
verified sort of
situation are they connected to soros i
i don't know okay
raw story just retracted tim an entire
pair they just
they just made something up what what
what did they make up eric
ross story made up an entire paragraph
about project veritas
oh they said they said that i said that
antifa was behind the capital rights
right i never said that so our attorney
sent they just deleted it
yeah and and as and i was like that's
great i got a retraction i'm framing the
retracto
but then i thought for every one of
these there's 50
000 that no one ever
got deleted and and i think to myself
they should be thanking
us for for doing a service because
but not for project veritas that that
paragraph would still be
on the internet forever on wikipedia
cited by other organizations
well it blows your mind wikipedia for
like seven years claimed i invented a
remote control zeppelin for live
broadcasting i have no idea how
cool but that's the that's the uh
editorial standard of wikipedia i
suppose
and that's right tim paul great zeppelin
inventor so say on wikipedia and the new
york times in their
response to our motion to dismiss cited
wikipedia beautiful in the legal motion
wait they really did they had footnotes
but but james o'keefe's wikipedia page
says that he's no good
i'm not making i am not making this up
you know what i'm not making this up
for a great lady has fallen uh so what
do you do you gotta start
this defense fund and then next time you
come on blow it up on the show like talk
about it and get people to start
investing in it well we're gonna we're
gonna start by
by issuing we already sue the new york
times and we're gonna start suing a few
other outlets i
i think this we're on to something here
malice defamation law in the united
states
well this this this is why discovery and
depositions are so dangerous to these
organizations because
i i've been in these private slack
groups or you guys know what slack yeah
it's basically discord for private
corporations right
i have seen these people say things that
would get them in very very serious
trouble
i have had there's one particular
instance i cite over and over again
about a very prominent individual who
now works for the new york times who
basically told me
hey we engage in unethical behavior so
don't report on other people doing the
same kind of unethical behavior
and i was like wow if a story broke
and they got sued and that chat was
released in discovery
the company would be their credibility
would be gone forever so how's discovery
work
so i've been through this so many times
i'm not an attorney i've got a few dozen
working for us
i dropped out of law school you you do a
motion to dismiss
it you pass this motion to dismiss
that's when these companies start
settling lawsuits like in the case of
nick covington
uh or nick from the company nick salmon
thank you
once you get past motion dismiss then
the companies realize you are headed
towards discovery
a deposition is where they videotape
they videotape me
for 12 hours i'm under oath and they
then the lawyers pepper me with
questions they look at your emails they
get everything related to the litigation
so i can open up the new york times's
emails i can look at every communication
it's against the law for them to delete
emails about me they have to preserve
their records about me
and i get and by the way a deposition
nobody likes it it's very
uncomfortable unethical people which we
are not unethical at project veritas we
always behave like people are watching
fear the deposition have you ever been
deposed negative
have you ever been deposed in uh uh
not not in this not in this kind of
that's a context so i've been i've been
deposed like a dozen times i've been to
federal jury trials i i
understand this process and it's very
uncomfortable i mean i've been i've also
been arrested by the fbi so there's that
but i've been through all this and and
and they're not used to this
they're not used to this and i it's
almost like a form of content when you
get
the executive editor of the new york
times in a chair
under oath it's almost like he's
required
to answer questions and and their brain
probably hurts because it requires
they're legally bound to tell the truth
they have to and their brain isn't used
to that so the withered husk in their
brain that is the truth center is like
struggling to function like pouring
water on a robot it's like
malfunctioning when you do discovery
you start pulling from the emails if you
find like different infractions if this
guy
said defamed you this guy defamed you
this guy defended you do they then
become
separate it's so beautiful in the new
york times case already
the reporter's name in that case uh uh
guys new york times reporter
maggie astor uh wrote an article this is
so beautiful in the article
she said that project veritas relies
solely on the anonymous sources in the
minnesota video
when you can see the people's faces it
was just preposterous it was
self-evidently incorrect
and then under oath maggie astor changed
her tune
under oath she already printed a
retracto
in the motion she already changed the
fact she said no no
many of the people are are named so
under oath they change their tune
well so that's that's that's that's a
that's a retraction that's a victory for
you that's a victory all right
they've now admitted the the facts are
different from what they've proposed
it's
already admitted but she knows she knows
she knows it and the judge knows it and
the jury knows it i'm telling you
this is the people's litigation defense
fund team that's a good idea
they've got a they've got to settle with
you they've got to just what concerns me
is the damages that that guy that girl
went on cnn in front of i don't know a
hundred thousand people do you have how
many people were watching
a million people and they lie about they
said that you were spreading false
information
this is what they did to me when i got
invited to the white house so uh
me and bill and you were there as well
when we got invited the white house
the today show showed my picture and
claimed that i was a proponent of the
seth rich conspiracy theory
they made it up because what happened
was
fox news reported definitively it was
fox business i believe
information about the seth rich
conspiracy theory i then
read that and said wow well i don't
believe it's entirely true but we'll see
what happens
because i read a story that was later
retracted they ignore
all of the context around the fact that
it was retracted that i came out when it
was retracted and said wow the story was
fake the whole time who'd have thought
but simply by reading a story that later
got rejected they claimed i was pushing
a conspiracy theory you see that works
that's that's a great trick because
they'll argue but it is true it was a
conspiracy theory yeah but at the time
the context is relevant it was a
definitively reported story from fox
business
later retracted i reported on the
retraction that's that's
that's the dirt of these organizations
they know it's not true they know it's a
manipulation
think about every single journalist who
pushed the insane russiagate lies
are they all conspiracy theorists now
well there's a there's a great book
called disinformation by a by a
by a soviet bloc dissident which i
tweeted this picture this guy died
yesterday
i can't even pronounce his name but he
wrote a book called disinformation he
was a
defector and he talks about how
disinformation works in the soviet union
or in his case
romania i believe spell out his name or
eon
m-i-h-a-i pop
he died yesterday and he wrote a book
called disinformation it's like it's
like a thousand dollars on amazon
because everyone's trying to buy it
right now
i have a copy of it and and he says that
there's always a little kernel of truth
in their disinformation and they always
go back to that
it's mostly untrue but there's some
weird like you just said little factoid
and um and that's how they do it that's
how disinformation works they'll use
some iota of truth and it's
and it's surrounded by falsehoods
assumptive language
yeah saying things like uh you know
james
they'll say james o'keefe pushed the
conspiracy theory that antifa was
responsible for the capital rights
right and then they'll argue in court we
didn't say that he affirmed
asserted as true we say he pushed the
the theory because he was talking about
it
like if i ask a question if you're
pushing the conspiracy theory i'm a
reporter right
so i ask questions for a living so if i
if i ask
questions about whether antifa was
present
and then one reporter from bloomberg
says he implied it raw story
says he's pushing the theory it's this
crazy thing and
and once it makes it through a few a few
sources it'll be
james o'keefe asked a question about x
then someone else copies that and says
according to source a james o'keefe was
asking
you know it is implying that x was true
and then the third
third source says james o'keefe said x
then wikipedia takes it
runs it james o'keefe believes in you
know space definitely it's like a game
of telephone
uh and and again the further it goes the
crazier it gets and people don't
understand this because they don't see
themselves doing this but people need to
understand the levels of the
depravity the amount of lies the the
amount of selective editing that goes
into a lot of these mainstream media
pieces
when they have an agenda and when they
have something that they want to push
they will do
everything in their power they will
stoop to levels that are unimaginable
just to get that agenda well with the
editing thing that's what i say in the
our videos is a form of psychological
projection this is that what you know
i'm not a psychologist but this is
this is projection they just quite
literally accuse their enemy of doing
and and and and we're not like that you
and i are that's not how we operate
we're fairly ethical people we're pretty
honest people
pretty down to earth people these people
project onto us what they do
and when they say editing i mean all
journalism is edited selectively so i
mean these words are arranged into
sentences in
a fairly deceptive manner they write
things i mean we do the purest form of
journalism as people's lips moving you
can hear the words coming out of their
mouth but they practice this form of
projection and it's
rather evil they they just a key and it
works tim
it's effective and they have like 100
million dollars set aside
annually for lawsuits getting ready to
pay out 40 million dollars a year in
lawsuits i'm just throwing a number i
don't know exactly
they do though they're they're well
prepared for lawsuits they they budget
them in
they know they're coming and they know
they can crush the little guy and that's
what you were saying they they
they railroad people they railroad
people and and i think i think
back k in the new york times's case that
that article about our minnesota video
was the night of the presidential debate
they had a researcher lined up from
stanford
it wasn't stanford university it's it's
some other stanford some
some unknown research group called
stanford i mean you can't make this
stuff up
they called the guy the reporter called
the guy that they had a canned remark
yeah it's quote probably part of a
disinformation campaign
probably and then the new york times
cited that researcher saying it's
probably part they put it in the
headline it was cross-referenced by usa
today
facebook uses usa today as their fact
checker and before you know it 50
million people getting a notification
saying
the video's fake news it's unbelievably
effective
well let's let's talk about the uh the
story you just broke yeah
and uh you know in talking about the
censorship now so you guys just put out
this tweet
mark zuckerberg actually i have the
tweet right here you tweeted
ceo mark zuckerberg takes anti-vaxx
stance in violation of his own
platform's policy
i'm not gonna read his quote because you
know even though i know you already did
but
then they might try i'll tell you what i
do when i read quotes i'll do this
quote i share some caution on this
vaccine because we
and this is mark zuckerberg saying this
just don't know the long term and again
mark zuckerberg
side effects of basically and again this
is from mark zuckerberg's quote
modifying people's dna mark zuckerberg
here and rna
no no i have to do that because they'll
selectively edit yes
yes no joke no joke me reading something
from mark zuckerberg and they will
splice it together well go ahead and
splice it that many times if you really
want to do it some people will
but this is mark zuckerberg basically
saying something that as far as i can
tell was never believed to be correct
when when the when when the research in
the news was coming about coming out
about the mrna vaccine
it was never true it was always a
conspiracy theory that it modified dna
now at the time it was not against
facebook's rules to claim that that's my
understanding that's correct right
at the time but recently facebook
announced that they are quote
expanding their efforts to remove false
claims on facebook about
the vaccine so mark zuckerberg makes
this statement in july
where he's essentially violating
facebook's own policy and the question
is
i guess mark zuckerberg's thinking has
evolved on the vaccine
and but it's a little bit strange
because
he's now just instituted this policy
prohibiting
what he was saying a few months ago well
i think it's fair to say
people's opinions change and mark
zuckerberg was clearly
wrong in this the mrna it essentially
doesn't change your dna it just
configures certain cells to produce the
spike protein
and then when those cells die off that's
it that's the end of it that's why
there's actually multiple doses that's
why they say
it doesn't work necessarily in the long
term but this was
i don't know what he was reading mark
zuckerberg was reading fake news
now it's fine in my opinion that he
wants to have an opinion that's
incorrect because
people are wrong even mark zuckerberg
the real issue here is you can see
and and we were talking about this
earlier zuckerberg has afforded the
right to pontificate on things that were
widely considered to be conspiracy
theories at the time
right whereas if i said the same thing i
would have been annihilated in the media
he's telling his own staffers this stuff
now he's implementing this rule and
again i'm not holding it against him
that he changes opinion
okay but the authority is him this is
the problem
who appointed mark zuckerberg to decide
when and how we're allowed
to think about things and share opinions
well his own vice president nick
clegg we had him on a leak tape
basically saying they're just making
this stuff up as they go
this is nick clegg vice president of
facebook he's a british guy and he's
on the i guess he has their oversight
board
and and they're basically playing the
role of judge and jury of the supreme
court
the financial times reported there is a
growing trend tech companies think they
should be
deciding public policy not government
and this is a prime example this has
nothing to do with my opinion about the
vaccine or whatever
or europe it doesn't the point is
zuckerberg is the ceo of facebook
and just a couple months ago he was
anti-vaxx
this is mark zuckerberg not me not you
not us it's mark
zuckerberg the ceo of maybe the most
powerful company in the history of the
planet earth
at a time when if you tweeted anything
remotely anti-vaxxed they went after you
hard but this is the ceo of facebook
anti-vaxx
on the record not on the record he's off
the record he's but he's closed doors
to a major i guess he's on the record to
his own staff
as his own executive committee saying
this this is a whistleblower inside
facebook folks has given us this tape of
mark zuckerberg that is one of
mark's own colleagues is a source to
james o'keefe
and is still a source to james o'keefe
that's why those engineers are very
careful right now
pretty cool pretty cool right and mark
zuckerberg just a few months ago said
i'm anti-vaxx
i think it changes your dna again mark
zuckerberg's words not mine
it's too late they gotcha but suddenly
now
mark zuckerberg has changed the policy
you're not allowed to even pontificate
about the vaccine
doesn't that seem a little capricious to
you i think i think it's
it's it's good that he finally realized
he was wrong i think this this is
actually included in your report that he
he did a public conversation with doctor
fab
and here's what i love about this
because i i texted you when i saw this
and i was like well look i get it if you
change his opinion
you guys fully included the dates of
when he said it the date of when he had
a change of opinion you're not hiding
the fact that
and i think it's fair to point out that
sometimes people's opinions change and
good good for mark zuckerberg i'm
realizing he was wrong
the issue is if it's wrong to say it now
we knew it was wrong to say it
you know back in july when he was
telling his employees this the point is
why was the rule just implemented why
was mark zuckerberg allowed to push
insane conspiracy theories to a massive
company facebook
just it's i guess the idea is if we're
going to live under this rule about
disinformation
you can clearly see that mark zuckerberg
shares disinformation
and then it only changes when he
realizes he was spreading his name
in many ways and and this nick clegg the
vice president of facebook is admitting
as much in in a leaked tape one of these
leaked tapes
saying we're kind of we're kind of
having to come up with these rules think
of it like the us constitution imagine
the united states constitution had
very specific things that you're not
allowed to say
one of them is you cannot speak about
the covet vaccine i mean that's what
facebook is saying
they're just making new things up that
you can't talk about
and the analogy i draw is the
constitution of the united states is
very clear
congress shall make no law prohibiting
the free exercise at the freedom of
speech but facebook has these rules
about
certain subjects you're not allowed to
pontificate
about and and the audience well they're
they're a private company they can say
what they want
their private i get their private
company but you can't
lie lying is wrong it's just unethical
i would even question the private uh you
know remark there because
they work hand in hand with the
government in many different ways so
that would say they're even a quasi
government agency not even from their
seed funding but from what they're doing
now
so it's interesting because i mean he's
afforded to change his mind he's allowed
he's allowed to pontificate but but
we're not
you know that's the thing when you when
you get rid of conversation when you
censor it when you stifle it
you spread a lot of these crazier
theories and then again it
deserves to be called out but i'm happy
someone's calling look at twitter
and hunter biden the this is one of the
biggest media scandals
of our generation a new story broke
about hunter biden
vice president job well now president
joe biden's son at the time
running for the the highest office in
the land and his son was implicated in
some very serious crimes and his brother
so twitter intervened facebook
intervened and they publicly bragged
don't worry we are suppressing this
story so people can't see it
and then what two weeks after the
election was over they were like oh that
story that was true the whole time
it was true the whole time that is
horrifying
and so this goes hand in hand uh i think
you're looking for some consistency the
consistency would be
mark zuckerberg says don't spread
disinformation we de-rank this
information
they give power to these third-party
fact-checking organizations which
just make stuff up and they put out fake
news themselves like my favorite was
uh snopes article did ocasio-cortez
exaggerate the danger she experienced in
the capital
false while she wasn't in the capital
the capital was stormed
no aoc's story about the capital
took place a full hour and ten minutes
before the building had been breached so
i think it is fair to have the opinion
she exaggerated
why then is snopes given the ability to
slap a warning label
on my posts which is in my opinion
they didn't actually do that to me i'm
just saying on on your or anyone else's
post
snopes can now put their opinion over
your opinion
if we're supposed to be living by a
standard to stop disinformation
i think what we've now realized from you
know the the video you've put out just
now
this is the context i think you need to
make sure people understand right that
in july it was a conspiracy theory to
say what mark zuckerberg was saying
and he didn't care he let people say it
now
he had the epiphany so he makes the rule
that's the problem
are we allowed to have these ideas and
communicate or is it only on mark
zuckerberg's whims the rules change
i mean this is an extraordinary point
tim i mean
it's like a constitution people need to
understand these companies just
okay now we're going to create a rule
this week saying you're not allowed to
talk about this
these are private companies again this
is from the financial times momentous
decisions in the hands of private
companies is not a long-term
public policy solution they neither have
the legitimacy nor the capacity
to make such decisions in the public
interest these are supreme court these
are akin to the supreme court decisions
for facebook to say okay now you are not
allowed to talk
about vaccines we will ban you it's it's
it's
more powerful than if the united states
supreme court were to cast a decision
tomorrow
saying you are not allowed to talk about
red delicious
so hold on is the rule actually that you
can't talk about vaccines at all or
i'm going to read the rule to you this
is last week mario i believe that
this is facebook announced last week a
new rule that said quote
we are expanding efforts to remove false
claims on facebook and instagram
about coved vaccines and vaccines
in general so i wonder you know be
really funny if like one day
mark zuckerberg just like he meets
somebody who he has this epiphany and he
becomes this crazy fruitarian who thinks
meat is wrong
right and then he passes a rule where
he's like i think that
eating meat is just wrong and eating
vegetables is also wrong you know
a lot of people talk about not doing
harm to animals but you also harm the
plant when you eat the vegetable
fruits are actually meant to be eaten so
i think everyone should have to eat
nothing but fruit and spread the seeds
so now we're going to ban anyone who
promotes meat or advertises it
that's exactly right right that's
exactly what happened insane because in
july he said no this thing is
i'm an anti-vaxx guy and i think it
modifies your dna this is like not
five ten years ago this was in 2020 he
said this
and suddenly he had a change of heart i
mean so i i think that that
facebook is more powerful than the
united states supreme court in fact
these tech companies that were powerful
all three branches of government so when
they make a rule change that says you
can't talk
about something it's it's as if the
united states
supreme court made a change about you
codify the united states constitution
give me the ability to control what
people say and i care not who makes the
law well the thing
is okay this is the big debate this is
it there's a big debate of our times
they're they're private companies right
now and we don't have the right to
seize their means of production as a
company that's that's very communist if
we were to say okay facebook now you're
government controlled
we're taking the country we're not going
to do that we're not seeing all the
means so we're not going to make them
create their own terms of service we
can't do that that's a communistic
takeover we can't do that listen to me
and
the problem is these companies have a
right to create their own terms
as as does a restaurant they don't want
you talking about certain things in the
restaurant get out of the restaurant
that's the restaurant owner's right
my concern is how do we move forward in
the society with that still being the
case and i can only find
tim please let me finish this thought
that we need to free the software code
it's the only way to allow other people
to create software as powerful as
facebook
with their own terms of service so you
made several points there and the
premise
of your final conclusion is incorrect
which is what i'm trying to address
scale exists if there is one person
buying up all the farmland and now no
one has food
the people have a right to say nah you
can't do that
one small plot of farmland has a right
to their sovereignty to grow their crops
and be left alone
one person seizing every single
opportunity for people to eat
is very different facebook is not some
small platform people use sometimes
it is the one of the largest if not it
is the second largest website i think on
the planet behind google
and they essentially control the flow of
information by by monopolizing it
they've now used that monopoly power to
control our politics
it is not the same thing as a restaurant
there's 50 different restaurants that
are not chains i can go to
there's no other facebook the president
is not on these other platforms okay i
agree
it is a monopoly but if you look at
rockefeller's standard oil
they broke it up that was the first
monopoly and all it did was make
rockefeller more rich
they created six new oil companies that
he had stock in all six so if they did
this to facebook
you'd have facebook prime you'd have
facebook messenger you'd have to
instagram the answer and zuck
no it's not the answer breaking up
facebook yes regulating it by freeing
the software code yes
why would bring the software code doing
it because it would give people the
opportunity to create software as
powerful with their own terms
and then people would migrate to the
place with the best terms you just
advocated against seizing the means of
production
now you're advocating for it no i think
that facebook has the right to function
and i would never want to take it away
from market the code is their means of
production the reason production is the
website
no the factory is yes what's what's the
website made of the code right
yeah so you want to give the secret
sauce that makes their system work yeah
but i'm not going to take their system
that's what you're advocating no i'm not
taking i don't want to take facebook i
want to
free the software code so other people
can create more of them
so you're taking it's different they're
allowed to keep their brand but not the
actual
and the website and all the marketing
that goes through the website yes of
course
that's that's the only in my that's the
only capitalist
solution i can find over the last two
years you're talking about transparency
i mean these are these are these are
these platforms uh
they have the ability to amplify certain
voices while excluding others
it's a product of you know scale
economies and and their power comes from
from squeezing out al alternative
platforms
while fueling this virality and
and i think i mean i agree with you on
one hand i think it's about transparency
i i'm
i'm biased veritas my mission i believe
in it if we just expose
how they do what they do you're talking
about like
letting their competitors know how how
how what do you mean by
by showing their what they're doing to
the source code access to the code so
you can see what the
how the algorithms work how the code is
built how the software's built so you
could reuse it
and if you make it a free software code
if you take the software and change it
make it better
they would have access to your changes
as well
interesting interesting
i don't know i think the the answer is
you know we had uh uh
will chamberlain on the show talking
about how parlor isn't the answer
we need platform access as a civil right
to make sure people have the ability to
use these platforms
but i got to be honest the problem is
multi-faceted so i'll give you one
example
just because i'm allowed to use twitter
does that mean twitter is functioning
properly
right so we talk about facebook
censorship and the capriciousness of
their rule changes well
recently i quote tweeted cassandra
fairbanks she was talking about she did
this story about vans pulling up to the
tcf center and questions being raised
about it
i said i didn't think the videos
mattered whatever they do prove or don't
prove i don't think they matter
because time magazine wrote an article
basically saying that a
you know the election was rigged and
then i put i'm sorry they didn't say it
was rigged
they say it was fortified by changing
election laws and manipulating the flow
of information
that's a fact they didn't say it was
rigged that's what i said they said it
was fortified
time magazine or this article twitter
blocked my tweet
in all forms you can't retweet it you
can't quote you can't respond you can't
like no
i'm sorry you can't quote you can't
respond retweet or like and they put a
tag saying
this claim about fraud is disputed but
it's literally
not disputed time magazine wrote it i
was quoting time magazine
so i actually reached out to jack and i
said could you remove this it is a false
statement of fact
jack did not respond but he responds
sometimes you know i talk to him every
so often
we have this other story that's really
funny actually and this exemplifies
the the great problem check this out
twitter labels indiana ag's tweet of
valentine's day meme
that election was stolen from trump this
is hilarious
todd rokita tweeted happy valentine's
day and there's an image that says
you stole my heart like a 2020 election
happy valentine's day
and twitter says this claim of election
fraud is disputed and this tweet can't
be replied to
retweeted or liked due to a risk of
violence chef's kiss
memes it's it's a meme he's not
literally saying there was fraud he's
mocking the idea it's donald trump as a
cartoon and he's making fun of it
you can't even post memes yeah they went
after a couple my memes too on instagram
and twitter just deleted them and i
didn't even know and i'm like wait
what's going on here why
me i mean they're satirical they're
meant to be funny that's funny that
that's that's
that seriously i don't think that's
going that's not going to make anyone
violent at all and and now we're at a
phase where instagram just announced a
few days ago
that they're going to be going and
snooping through your dms your private
messages
looking for hate speech to go after
that's not new
i know but them publicly announcing it
right i think
and being so bold and boldened by it is
new we have to acknowledge the reality
that uh
that these platforms are i think we've
all been talking about this
they have a form of concentrated
political power
akin to basically a loaded gun on the
table they swing elections they sway
elections so what do we do about it
right that's what everyone says to
to me it's like okay stop complaining be
brave do something
i i i kind of agree with you i think
it's
exposing the reality and
we need an army of whistleblowers inside
big tech well you know
i've said this several times i think the
work you guys do is some of the most
important work we have right now
in like just your show brought us
richard hopkins last time i was on the
show
the mailman from uh from um pennsylvania
erie pennsylvania
sent us an email after watching your
show
and blew the whistle on the postal
service uh science that's
david that's all you man i mean we're
just a bunch of people who sit on the
sit around talking about stuff on the
internet but for whatever reason he
watches your show
more than the other show and he came to
prairie veritas veritas tips at
protonmail.com awesome
shameless plug that's v-e-r-i-t-a-s tips
at protonmail.com it's encrypted
hopefully the nsa is not intercepting
that email
and uh and that richard came to us and
richard lost his job
tim richard was fired from the postal
service first he was suspended then he
was fired by the way
i think that's important because he has
skin in the game he's an actual person
who's going to lose his career for the
public's right to know something he's
not just saying something
he's giving up his livelihood here's
here's why i say what you do is so
important and
actually why what you know richard and
others have done is
even more important i mean for one you
can't do your job unless there's brave
people willing to stand up and work with
you to get that information out more
importantly
those brave people who are standing up
are creating this atmosphere
where these big shots these fat cats
these corrupt individuals now to keep
looking over their shoulders wondering
who's going to say you can't do that i'm
going to i'm essentially going to blow
the whistle
it's like you were mentioning earlier
you know people at facebook now have to
worry
who's the person there who's going to
share what they're saying luke when you
when they go to look at dms which is
unconscionable and unethical for someone
to browse private dms
in the back of that whatever engineer
coder's mind is
wait before i look at the dm should i be
worried if someone's looking at me
that that that psychological effect
exactly and this is why they don't
have any transparency or accountability
to their actions because if they did
people would know what they can and
cannot say
they don't want you knowing it because
they want this fear effect they want
this chilling effect
where you have to worry about your butt
and worry about what you're thinking
about
because when you're when you're
censoring words you're censoring what
people can think
essentially and we also have to
understand on the bigger point here
these are not
private capitalistic entrepreneurship
organizations
you look at the seed funding liquid
there came from look right now at their
tax incentives the visa programs
their data sharing surveillance programs
the government contracts that they
receive
these are entities that are in line with
a lot of government institutions that
are working hand-in-hand
with government is downstream from these
institutions yes and and then they work
hand in hand
and they're pushing this agenda together
and i think once we address
that we have to understand these are not
just private entities that are private
companies pick and choose they're not
they're not that at all they are
monopolies at least that's a great
observation i was thinking as we were
talking that there could be some
software developer that's like i'm going
to blow the whistle on facebook i'm
going to deliver all the code to project
veritas that wouldn't work
because unless we use the government to
regulate these people
and to actually change the software
license uh and do it right
you could get rid of the code and they
can just change it so
we have to we have to acknowledge that
these guys are are
basically quasi government organizations
and should be treated such
yeah yeah well for the time being
i mean things are demoralizing yeah i
want to leave twitter i don't want to
leave twitter but when i see the way
they're treating you
like this ridiculous well i can tell you
right now there's someone watching this
who does work for twitter or google or
facebook i guarantee it
and we have so many sources and
whistleblowers coming to us right now
it's beyond you what you can fathom i
mean we have
untold dozens over a hundred
whistleblowers right now recording
watching i'm talking about the ceos of
these companies
and if you're watching this right now
just like uh just like richard hopkins a
few months ago
send us a note i think the solution is
exposure i think they don't fear the
united states government anymore
these all these people these politicians
are they they almost like they suck up
to cnn they
all they ever do is go on cnn i don't
even know what these congress critters
actually
do what do they actually do because all
i ever see them doing
is going on instagram which is owned by
mike zuckerberg
and going on television do they actually
create any laws i guess they don't
because government is in a state of
sclerosis so they can't pass legislation
so all they do is go on tech platforms
they are
beholden to tech they suck on the teat
of big tech
where would aoc be without twitter and
instagram nowhere
all the government just like alexander
solzhenitsyn said
uh the media has more power than all
three branches of the government and
what laws are they beholden to
when they say you are not allowed to
talk about this
or that it is akin to the united states
supreme court
changing the constitution and saying uh
you know first amendment appointments
except when you talk about
you know applesauce you know something
really crazy that i was reading
and uh guys definitely if you're
listening fact check me on this one i
was reading
some a post as a conservative post of
this that trump's own lawyer in the
impeachment trial
believed the very fine people hoax up
until he had to research the evidence
to defend donald trump then realized the
media
had been selectively editing what trump
had said and trump definitively
denounced white supremacy after after
charlottesville
and well the media cuts it out of
context like they did with the shinzo
abe fish feeding thing
and this lawyer didn't know that about
trump until he was investigating because
he had to go over the evidence how many
people think they're informed
because they read the news they read
what facebook allows to be shared
and they actually are just being fed
garbage the amount of fake news
disinformation and propaganda out there
is absolutely insane to even
fathom sometimes uh it's like 1984 two
plus two equals five is just keep
being repeated you know that's a real
thing though right there i know i know
it's
i've seen i've seen everything i've seen
it unfold but james the one question i
really wanted to ask you here when you
got hit by twitter was there any
alternative social media platform that
you were looking into fully
transitioning
away from twitter so i i take a unique
position on this because i
i i may take a stance that tim you don't
agree with her luke you don't agree with
i think that content is king that that
i i believe in distribution by proxy in
other words if they ban me everywhere
which everyone's warning me about okay
whatever they ban me everywhere and i
get a and i get a hidden camera video of
a federal judge taking a bribe
that's a 30-second video i would simply
send an email
to my 500 000 people on my email list
saying please download this video and
upload it to your twitter
and they can't ban every so content is
king
content not platform is king i've always
believed that
everyone wants to create another
platform i i i thought this in the back
of my head about parlor by the way
parlor got banned
okay we're gonna create another parlor
apollo's back parlor's back
but but and then i saw a parlor banned
milo today and now he's back oh he's
back to okay well
there's all these updates about the
platform but at the end of the day
content is
king i didn't coin that phrase that was
uh the viacom
ceo i forgot his name but i i i believe
that um
what was going through my mind luke was
that content is king
a good story will effuse its way and
distribute
it you know its way sort of like the
black goo
in the movie prometheus it will just
sort of get out there and there'll be a
new paradigm
i don't know what the name of the next
or the future platform will be
but what i do know is a good story is
always lurking behind
every corner and and again distribution
by proxy so telegram
we had 4 000 followers a couple weeks
ago now we have 350
000 followers and what we'll do is we'll
send a vimeo link and say please
download this clip and upload it into
your twitter
so if we're banned on twitter citizens
can
can can do it what are they going to ban
everyone
they can't do that this is the funny
thing you know when tiktok
had a bullying problem there were people
being mocked for their appearance or
their weight
they realized something whereas twitter
bans
the hate speech to protect the minority
tick tock realized
well if we want to stop the bullying and
we ban say
a thousand people bullying this person
that's a thousand users we lose in our
annual reports for
shareholders why don't we ban the person
being bullied
then there's no more bullying so tic tac
actually targeted
the person who was a victim of the of
the insults
that was clever in the uh i bring that
up just because
in the instance of twitter well they
can't ban everybody because then they're
gonna have to issue a report saying we
lost x many users this quarter oh we
banned them because we didn't like what
they had to say
yeah they can't ban us today because
they ban us for the zuckerberg story
every reporter that talks about it will
have to say
there's no doxing here it's zuckerberg
on tape you know you know the problem is
right now though
it's not fun anymore it's not what it's
not fun
part twitter used to be fun
but they're getting rid of interesting
people seeing a trump tweet was
hilarious
you know that the journalists would have
panic attacks when trump would tweet
that's weird
but i thought it would be funny when
trump would tweet something really silly
you know
like not that he should have most of the
time but
sometimes he would tweet funny and silly
things what did he tweet oh yeah when
elizabeth warren was drinking the beer
remember this
and her husband walks up and then she's
like thanks for being here
trump tweets what do you mean he's
supposed to be there it's his house that
was hilarious
it made it made it exciting they're
getting rid of anything that's that's
like even remotely interesting on the
platform
i mean and and if they ban us today for
publishing
a video tape of zuckerberg every
reporter who reports in the band will
have to include the facts about what
mark zuckerberg said that's why they
won't ban us
tim i think there's a lot to this whole
litigation
my producer just texted me that's genius
tim helping
helping others with the litigation fund
that's a really important idea
because so many people get defamed and
and we have a recourse
in in in the theory of defamation law
especially if they're not public figures
and i'm a public figure i have to prove
what's called actual malice i have to
prove the person
knew they were lying about me when they
lied but a non-public figure tim
if you're railroaded discovery this is a
really good
idea i don't i think the people the
reason people haven't done this is
because they don't know they can do it
and it takes like i call it balls
resources and willpower
balls or or or huevos fortitude cuevos
cuevos that's the uh the politically
correct terminology eggs
eggs and and i think it's a great idea i
think it's an excellent idea
called the people's defamation fund pdf
yeah pdf files pdf
yeah and people already you know it's
already in the back of their mind pdf
they know they say the idea is one
percent of it
99 is the execution but still i think if
you launched uh
not a gofundme because they would ban
you into yeah but if you launched a
any one of these other pla any any other
fundraisers you'd instantly raise enough
to just hire
uh an executive manager or whatever to
run the fund listen i'm gonna say it on
your show right now
if we get the new york times to give us
money which i
i'm betting my reputation on it so it's
going to happen we're going to use some
of those proceeds to start this um
this idea that you have i like this idea
i mean you mean the idea that i brought
up
the idea that you have it doesn't matter
but i named it but another thing to
i mean i remember starting off and i was
when i was still just you know
no one not a big reputation getting
slandered and attacked by the mainstream
media and also other instances where
they literally
took my videos that i did my live
reporting on protest
and they claimed it as theirs so many
times didn't they call you
like a non-shrinking violet or something
yes that was the new yorker
what was that quote that was an of the
uh lukerdowski is armed with a video
camera and a youtube channel and
definitely is not a shrinking violet
uh that was the new york times
perspective and that was actually
you know fair reporting on their part
which was really interesting because
they actually quoted me correctly when
other news organizations literally took
quotes out of context put them together
to make them sound bad
or as if i was pushing for some kind of
violent action which i of course never
was i believe in total non-violence
always have always have advocated for
that but but for them especially when i
was starting off
especially when i didn't have a big
following they would just take
everything i did
take my live reporting take my photos
take my videos claim it as theirs
and then when i became prominent they
started slandering me and i'm like
what's what's going on here
i actually started talking to some
lawyers and uh
let's just say they don't steal my
videos they don't steal my photos
anymore but a lot has changed in the
last seven eight years
a lot the world has changed the new york
times went real
yeah we were talking about this
yesterday with will because you know
even
even with that new york times uh you
know weapons of mass destruction lie
there is still some kind of
understanding that the new york times
tries to tell the story and even then
when they go when they got caught with
the wmds they they admitted it they
talked about it
they they there were some repercussions
behind it
miller yeah yeah they they faced some
real actions because of that
still not enough comparatively to the
lie that they sold the american public
and the hundreds of thousands of people
that died and the
radicalization and immigration crisis
that came out of it but
but still not enough but still there was
still this kind of veil understanding
that
that that they're trying that they made
a mistake that that that you know
they're going to do their best they even
interviewed me a couple times and they
did
honest real reporting but but now all of
that's gone
that whole perception that whole
understanding that they're even trying
they're not even trying anymore
they're blatantly slapping the american
people upside the face
they're obsessing about race they're
obsessing about all this other stuff
that divide and conquers us so we fight
each other
and we don't focus on the real issues
the actual things that do affect us
uh especially after 2012 their their
decline
is evident and they're not the same new
york times that they're known for
let's let's jump to super chats and you
know normally i like to read as many as
possible but
i'm going to try and find as many
questions for james as possible you know
because
a lot of the comments are just general
you know comments on stories and forgive
me if you guys
i will read a bunch of super chats don't
get me wrong but i think it's a good
opportunity for people to get questions
in for james if they haven't had the
chance to
i'll start with one of the most
important aurora isabella says
this is a statement james o'keefe james
o'keefe is hot af
with a sweating face that was very
important to let you know
about that you know maybe i should i'm
not going to say
modeling shots no i was going to say i'm
not going to say it
riley uh luann says james how can i help
i've got media skills
cgi but no real revenue source at the
moment and i'm certainly not afraid of
speaking out
online or in real life how can i best
help to take these corrupt a-holes down
so prager says there's three you know
three
sorts of people in this in this life uh
those who uh
fight those who donate to those who
fight and those who do nothing
so i suppose you're not the third so you
can either you can either wear a camera
strap a camera to your body tim you can
um
what's her name what's the person what's
the person who asked the question
oh i i you can either put a camera on
your body you can you can find someone
in your network who works for an
organization that wants to blow the
whistle to be your citizen reporter
riley luand
riley or you could donate a tax exempt
donation to project veritas those are
your two options pick one
very cool colin stevens says tim please
recommend
james reach out to nick requieta of
wreck yet a law he's also a youtuber and
has talked about building a support
network with lawyers for situations like
this before
nick requieta i think that's a guy whose
name was banned
no that's that's not the how do you
spell the last name r r-e-k-i-e-t-a
all right this is a youtuber sent to
sent to my team thank you
yeah mitch stu says i tried posting a
positive comment about james multiple
times
it kept giving me an error message and
took a screenshot tim this is the same
thing with your live stream title james
is the new alex jones
well maybe listen if that happens
videotape your screen
i mean i get messages like this all the
time some of them are bunk some of them
are real i mean i'm sure it happens
uh again what's more interesting is a
hidden camera video of the engineer
or the coder in real time eating doritos
high-fiving each other
let's mess with james o'keefe's
instapage that's what the video i want
or it's stopping us from looking at the
the looking at this is not me i'm
quoting somebody
the dick pics on twitter remember that
guy clay
uh clay haynes from twitter clay haynes
from twitter
we got him on hidden camera in san
francisco bragging about yeah we look at
people's dick pics on the dms
i mean that was extraordinary i want to
see those videotapes yeah the nsa was
doing that before it was cool though
they were doing that
over 10 years ago but we need the
videotape of the nsa people doing it
james well nsa officers got caught
spanking it to people's private images i
confronted general hayden
about this he denied it and i have to
confront him with the actual news
article and then he's like
wait he ran away hayden the one that
lied under oath about the fourth
amendment stuff
it's hard to know because all of them
lie under oath especially if they're
former cia
and we have mike pompeo bragging about
it one of them like scratched his head
like on james clapper clapper yeah it
was like this guy's a spy and he's like
the worst liar ever he's like
he's like not wittingly we don't spy on
people if you're gonna lie at least
try to like well mike pompeo says they
get taught how to lie steal
that was the worst that's in there that
was the worst lying ever
yeah it's like a spook like i i did not
spy i mean
at least i mean these are bad spots
think about
the amount of viewership we've lost
because we couldn't include your name in
the title
the amount of viewership you lost we
couldn't include my name in the title
we put the name of our guests in the
title of the show so people know
because often you know when we have say
jack murphy or will or you know or james
o'keefe
there are a lot of people who maybe not
wouldn't normally watch the show but
want to see this particular perspective
when we tried to stream with your name
in it it didn't work
when i changed title removing your name
it worked now the title is youtube is
giving us the business won't let us
stream
a lot of people are clicking that see
what's going on and they're going oh
whoa it's james oh man
imagine if they got an email
notification saying james o'keefe on the
show you're like 900 you'll get like
times 40 50 well it would be times 80
all the people who want to hear what you
had to say and it's not just about you
james it's about
any other guest we would have where it
for some reason is not allowing us to do
it now i'll tell you this
is it possible it was just a crazy old
glitch it is possible just a
glitch you know yeah well i'm sorry i'm
at the point in my life where the
glitches always ever fl
always flow in one direction full
conspiracy
no no so what i'm saying is at a certain
point you want you want to say
that you know the make the least amount
of assumptions someone corrected me on
occam's razor
what is more likely well when we know
they actively censor conservatives when
they literally just censored
suspended project veritas on twitter for
ridiculous bs reasons
and we know they did and then i tried to
have james on the show with his name in
the title and it doesn't work
i think it's simpler to say glitches
have well let's
but they only they happen like come on
man at a certain point
it it there are more assumptions and it
just so happens that james is being
censored at the exact same time
on mine i'd get messages like these
glitches only happen when it's me doing
it but you know how many people are
having that experience like yeah it only
happens to you
the truth is very powerful saint
augustine said the truce is like a lion
i'd like to hear more more questions if
you have them oh yeah we got more
oh yeah yes but i've got you know i have
to go through and find them sure
all right let's see
i have to go through them so i'll just
i'll grab some for the for uh
for in the meantime as we scroll through
because there's a lot i don't want to
leave people up
milton bradley said i'm sorry uh elusive
gator says tim would you be willing to
invite don jr trump's son on your show
would you invite him
yes that'd be fun 100 uh whenever he
would like to come on
tom saltzman says hi tim could you and
your crew please start a real
fact-checking website
we are absolutely planning on doing that
but i'm also curious
if uh if you guys are planning on doing
that james any kind of
a real fact-checking website or just
general reporting i know you guys do
investigative work yeah but what about i
think we have to focus on our on our on
our
sort of uh mission which is to be the
answer to the question what can i do i
was talking to uh
a very popular uh of host of a major
news
television and he said everyone asks
what can i
do and i feel like that's my purpose in
life is to be the answer to that to that
so i have to keep
focused i don't want to lose my my focus
and be a fact checking
of everything well that being said we
have another question stan
t double zero says james love your work
curious has any leftist submitted
stories
versus conservative parties to project
veritas keep up the great work leftist
submitted stories in the sense of
exposing uh non-conservatives i i i
think he's saying have you gotten
leftists trying to expose conservatives
or people on the right
i know if someone's doing something
wrong or corrupt
i'll publish it i i did a story on a
republican ballot harvester in texas
that she was arrested by the attorney
general named as richard regas in new
hampshire the attorney general of new
hampshire
republican we exposed someone who voted
multiple
times so at the end of the day there was
the jeffrey epstein
clip that we got from abc news owned by
disney and uh this was a leaked
recording of amy robach a year and a
half ago
and this was a non-republican or so i
think veritas over time will expand in
many directions
i love the idea when they claim that you
target leftist groups and you you went
after
you you've investigated google the
washington post the new york times
yeah sort of a tacit what is that these
institutions are leftist you only go
after left-wing groups like the new york
times
washington post okay well there's your
answer folks
yeah yeah yeah all right michael smith
says
with all these barriers to open
discussion lockdowns and censorship what
do you see we can do to help affect
public opinion
i have thought about getting more
involved in local government thoughts
keep it simple i'm a guerrilla much love
gorilla yes indeed i thought you put
this because i'm we're a guerrilla
journalist i didn't know if that was
right it's alex jones created a meme
coincidental yeah
um skin in the game is a term that my
colleague eric cochran used who blew the
whistle on pinterest eric
cochran said i have to have skin in the
game
because we only live our lives for so
long life is short
my advice to you is service to is to get
involved locally and
to and to be an investigative reporter
on on the local level as
luke has has done and you know
it'll mean something after you're gone
and i think we don't realize
you know i think people are beginning to
wake up and understand that we have to
be
the media stop complaining about how
biased they are and just go out and do
their jobs i mean when i did the acorn
story
10 years ago i walked in in baltimore
maryland
my colleague hannah was dressed like a
miami hooker she was 20 years old
and within minutes these pseudo
government agents were telling us how to
disguise underage hookers as dependents
on our tax forms
it was amazing how easy it was
to just get people to just talk just
be a journalist to go out and do it it
doesn't you don't need that much
training just take a camera and go start
asking questions and jon stewart
sang your praises saying journalists
where are you look at this kid look what
he's doing the united states senate
voted 83 to 7 and democratically
controlled house in the senate to defund
acorn that was 10 years ago
and this is a girl that messaged me
hannah messaged me on facebook i've
never met her before she said james
you think it'd be a good idea to go into
acorn dressed as a hooker now most
people
get these sorts of yeah slide into the
dm
slide into the dms they delete them as
spam i said that's a great idea there
should be a pimp in the situation
and you know be a citizen journalist go
out there and just go do it
robert bettel says he who controls the
feed controls the world
i propose forcing by law the algorithm
to be open source
and the choice of which algorithm and
third-party filter service be moved to
the end
user i think it's a it gets really
i don't know esoteric when when talking
about the code and the source and how we
deal with that
and that's one of the challenges they
rely on this not only
opaque system but even if they did
release the code most people are going
to look at it and say i have no idea
what that is i have a different
perspective
a little bit than i think the solution
is for the ceo or the vice president
these companies come out and say
in congress we are trying to elect
democrats
if they just said that i'd be happy i
wouldn't be happy
i'd be it'd be a start it'd be a good
start
it because if the code or whatever it is
i'm not an engineer so excuse my
ignorance but whatever it is that we're
talking about here
somewhere in that code shows them
targeting
shadow banning uh let's say tim we had a
san francisco
engineer at google quite literally
writing code as we speak
targeting this podcast and he was under
oath in congress and he said
uh you know congressman smith i targeted
tim poole's podcast and here's the code
showing me doing it because i hate tim
poole
i want to destroy james o'keefe and i
want to elect democrats thank you very
much
i'd be very happy my problem with
relying on the ceos or executive is is
that
it's not a good and evil thing for me
it's a thing about it's
justice because if if if you rely on the
ceo to do the right thing
and reveal themself they're going to
sell the company and then you're going
to have to rely on another human
and another human and that's allows for
corruption to breed
i just think the system should be
transparent and not even open source but
free software like gpl general public
license or the mit license
so that changes are made to it those
changes are also free
the challenge james with what you were
saying about the guy saying here's the
code is that they're not going
to say that i mean i'd love it too
they're going to do what we've already
seen these big tech companies do
there is no bias we do not ban people
for public opinion
you know for their political opinions
and then they just say we only ban for
rule violations
and our rules are extremely specifically
uh specific and politically
it's a cognitive dissonance do you think
they've convinced themselves or do you
think oh secretly
yeah you know i mean just look at uh i i
know it's brought up so often but
the joe rogan episode with you know it
was really joe
when jack didn't understand when i told
him to his face
your rules are biased against
conservatives he said we don't ban
people for being conservative for their
political opinions i said yes you do
because your rules are biased against so
this is from the orwell book 1984 where
they're actually their cognitive
dissonance is to such a degree where
they've actually convinced themselves
not to actually internalize or think of
the word doublethink because in doing so
they're admitting they're tampering with
reality
so you're saying psychologically even
when they tuck themselves under the
covers at night
they don't individually and personally
think that they're helping
democrats is that what you're saying so
so in the instance of jack dorsey it was
a really fascinating revelation
when i told him you have a policy
against misgendering people
to conservative americans of which half
the country or
or you know a little bit more a little
bit less they believe that if someone is
born biologically male
you must use you know he him pronouns
whereas the left believes it's based on
identity
those are two different world views your
rule set
penalizes the conservative worldview
therefore
a conservative who expresses their
worldview will be banned from your
platform
your rules are biased against the
conservative worldview
and it was like the first time he had
ever heard that like he didn't realize
in their minds 99.9 of americans
hate donald trump are all progressives
and it's just this silly
fringe far right oh those dang far right
how did 75 million people vote for
donald trump they were tricked by by
lies that must be it
it's like it's like you know you know
the principal skinner meme am i out of
touch
no it's the children who are wrong
that's that's them they don't get it no
matter
how many times that's that's that's
straight out of 1984.
that's out of the uh the manual uh uh
the emmanuel goldstein manual that
george orwell
hypothesized which is that it's to
believe that black is white and then to
change your mind and never to have
previously thought that black is white
and
and you can't even talk about double
think it's a strange psychosis then tim
if what you're saying is true i don't
know if i agree with you
i think there's there's a substantial
minority of these engineers and folks in
silicon valley
that have an intentionality behind how
they code that that that do have an
agenda and that would privately admit
this no definitely i think that
that there's a substantial minority and
therefore the mission is to expose that
intentionality
but i think you're also right that
there's also a substantial minority of
people
who have are like the goldstein manual
in orwell's 1984 and they have
they have this cognitive dissonance
where they don't even
concede the notion of doublethink
and they've convinced themselves through
some type of strange psychosis
do you know what happens when someone is
experiencing cognitive dissonance and
you prevent you you present absolute
proof
that their worldview is incorrect or at
least a portion of it you know you know
what their reaction is
blind rage this is why you see those
videos of the famous memes of people
like their veins are popping out and
they're screaming
and that's why you see so often the meme
of the cool as a cucumber guy
you know poking fun at them the person
who is not emotionally agitated
who has thought through their problems
who has thought through the problems and
looked at the information
has the arguments right at hand for the
most part i don't think every single
person on the right has all the answers
but you'll see a lot of these
ideologically driven woke culti leftist
type individuals pro-censorship
experiencing the positive cognitive
dissonance of trying to claim their for
free speech while almost also
simultaneously
being in favor of censorship they can't
handle it
they make up like there's that famous
comic
where the guy says that the paradox of
tolerance which
it's a paradox itself like the comic
itself makes literally no sense because
it contradicts itself
they can't see through this eventually
when they're confronted by information
that proves it
they snap they get angry they get
violent they get rage right
it's a defense mechanism and when you
have an a social media admin that's
feeling rage that's when the bands
happen
exactly so the way it was explained to
me and this could be absolutely wrong
it's been a long time this is it was it
was explained to me by
some um a psychologist i think what they
basically said was
you grow up you know you're a little kid
you're you're you're
you're pre-teen you're a teenager you're
a young adult and you're building a
world view
you're in your mind you are determining
what is true and what isn't
by the time you're you're you know
getting into your late teens into your
early 20s your brain is sort of now
constructed a solidified worldview that
is nearly complete
at a certain point your brain says this
is true
it must be true because you've survived
for this long
whatever it is that you've learned has
helped you survive in this dangerous
treacherous world
so it is dangerous to have those ideas
and that worldview challenged
because if it turns out you're actually
believing something that could be
dangerous for you it could put your life
at risk
the simplest way to explain it is back
when humans were running through the
fields in the savannahs
we learned hey you know fire hot and
your brain builds this world view that
fire is hot people believe these things
and their social circles they they you
know basically solidify and fortify this
world view
once you get to a certain age you need
to maintain that world view
because it will keep you alive all of a
sudden someone comes around and
completely shatters that world view
putting your life at risk it's a defense
mechanism where by getting emotionally
enraged it shuts down your ability to
process the information
to protect what has kept you alive for
this long it's essentially a
you know a fail-safe that actually
backfires in the long run i think what
concerns me
i would love to hear your opinion on
this is that people are for the most
part
lacking critical thought maybe not all
but and i know we can learn critical
thought but
even people that are massively
intelligent developers or
fantastically wealthy business tycoons
lacking critical thought where if
someone challenges your worldview and
says something you think
is threatening your safety you're still
supposed to support their ability to do
that
under the u.s constitution i go back to
orwell constantly because i feel like
this book
answers so many of these questions and
what scares me about the orwell book is
when
winston the protagonist this is the
winston smith
is being tortured by o'brien the tyrant
and and and
every one of us has got fear is imagine
your worst fear in the world i'm not
going to
say to my enemies what it is and and the
or
what is it bees close
you're on the right track um and the t
tyrants have figured out
that they have they have winston uh
they've put a cage on his face and they
put a rat the biggest fear of winston is
a rat
and he says two plus two equals five
please tell us that two plus two equals
five when says no no two plus two equals
four
and the tyrant opens up the door and the
rats coming towards his face
and finally winston says okay two plus
two is whatever you want it to be
two plus two is whatever you want just
don't put the rat in my face
none of us are that strong none of us
are that i don't care don't tel
think of what your worst fear is in the
whole wide world could be
i don't know spiders bees whatever none
of us are that strong i i don't i don't
agree i don't i don't agree with you
four lights you know that reference
do you know the reference there are four
lights ever a bunch of people watching
are going yes
it's uh it's from the next generation
star trek
captain picard is kidnapped and tortured
by the kardashians
and there are four lights in front of
him and he keeps saying there are five
lights now tell me how many lights are
there
and picard refuses to say there are five
lights and he says there are four lights
was he tortured
yeah yeah he was tortured deprived of
sleep all of the you know
yeah he was tortured he was like
disheveled and shaking and he refused to
back down
well i mean this is this is the question
that that this is
to go to your point but yet we live in a
society
where there's there's there's courage
there's the courage to run up the hill
with a bayonet
you know von klossowitz talks about two
different types of courage and then
there's moral courage
where the hell is the moral courage in
washington dc well we're not asking
people to give their lives we're giving
they're asking them to give up their
reputation
and open and orwell's hypotheses is that
no one is that strong
the protagonist winston smith is forced
to say that two plus two equals five or
a rat eats his face
okay and winston says okay whatever two
plus two equals five and orwell sells to
orwell says to tell deliberate lies
while genuinely believing them to forget
any fact that has become inconvenient
and then when it becomes necessary again
to draw black back from oblivion for
just so long it is as needed
to deny the existence of objective
reality so these
silicon valley people are are
are these tyrants telling us this two
plus two equals five
it's a great metaphor because i feel
like we're being scared
through social media into into this
spirit of what
uh race or social media i have people in
the conservative
movement i don't even consider myself
part of that movie afraid
to retweet me for fear of being what
that we're not talking about
those are cowards well there's a lot of
them my friend but it's absolutely
absolutely it's like
i want to add air people so that they
become they're not even we're not
talking about
spiders and bees and rats we're talking
about
the possibility of being censored on
twitter if that's the thing that they're
scared of
we're in trouble fellas well i think you
mentioned that you think nobody has that
strength to reject the rat
people aren't people are forget rats and
bees and tarantulas
you do it every day you spit in the eye
of the establishment machine every
single day and so do we
i think that you do that you do that and
you do i mean
listen i can come on here and talk about
movies sometimes like i did
gina carano star wars you know and it's
kind of wagging the finger at these
corporations
they don't care that i don't that i'm
mad at them because they fire gina
chrono
you put a camera in the face of these
people so you know
i think there are people who are willing
to say
there are four lights two plus two
equals four you're one of them
and i think there are a lot of people
who are cowards and the problem is
you know the thing is i'll tell you this
i i've been i've been having this kind
of joking thing
it's sort of a joke say one good thing
about antifa as like it's kind of a joke
about
like lowering temperature and stuff and
i'll tell you this they're brave
they're angry they're passionate and
they're willing to sacrifice
everything to get what they want and i
think they're dangerously incorrect
too many people on the right are
absolutely not willing to sacrifice
anything why is that i don't know man
because they're scared and they're fat
and happy
because they get to sit back in their in
their lounge chair watching
you know whatever hollywood movie they
claim to hate but still get to be a part
of something they've been given enough
money to survive and then they're
threatened with it being taken away
because they're they're living in fear
so they don't speak up so i
i often say it's it's not black and
white it's not like
we're i'm gonna say we will always defy
the machine
when it comes to saying a certain name
of you know
which we can't say on youtube i've
chosen but we're not gonna say it why
i prefer to have this show live with
james o'keefe and you know ian and luke
and lydia were talking about what's
going on
and why it's dangerous and important i
could choose to say one
word or one phrase and get the whole
conversation removed i won't do that
that's not about fear that's about tap
yeah but james is talking about torture
when you're
under duress of torture none of us have
ever been there we would have
told each other if we have i think more
people are willing to risk their lives
than their own
reputations think about it how many
people in washington dc are willing to
risk their reputation
for a cause greater than themselves i
can't think of maybe one or two
i can think of many folks who've made
the ultimate sacrifice sacrifice that is
beyond
anything i can comprehend go overseas
and die for their country
i can't think of many members of
congress or people
working in government that would be
willing to make
even a sacrifice of their own reputation
for a cause greater themselves forget
because they're they're not interested
in something some
uh they're not interested in values
they're not interested in preserving
freedom liberty and accountability
that's a
that's a problem it absolutely is and i
think
that's the main problem the left is it's
not so much that antifa
has a core set of values they're
fighting for it's that they're extremely
angry and they can be weaponized by the
collective because they fall in line
because they have tool kits they have
these plans and the right is more
individualist
that and there are a lot of people on
the right who are entirely
self-interested
and that's why they wouldn't retweet you
that's ridiculous
that that to me is is sad and pathetic
so you think sacrificing
our reputations is is i think
i think this road to to truth i i've
been doing this for 12
years and i've been through a lot of
pain i've been through there are moments
of of
ups and downs where i thought it was
over i mean i've been i've been in
federal prison and i first
falsely accused i mean of something i
did not do that's a very
and everyone abandoned me in that moment
no no everyone thought i was done
james you're over including my mentor so
i know what it's like
and i and i know that the the road to
uh truth and justice you're gonna go
through this and i
i don't think people are willing to and
it's and it's a political
political prosecution and to be and to
be tarred and feathered
is is is almost ins and the mind in this
in the psychology of the american people
is almost worse than death
because i can i can see people with the
courage to jump
run up a hill with a bayonet but i'm i i
a more rare form of courage is
is moral courage that is to stick by a
cause which is losing
they don't believe in themselves i don't
know i don't know why that is i don't i
don't
i i think that's that's the question
because if you can solve that question
you can actually change things
i'll tell you what it is that i'm
arrogant i
know i don't think i know everything but
when i do the research and i and i and i
assess the situation i look at these
political positions and i come to a
conclusion i don't come to it easily
which is why people call me a milk toast
defense sitter
when it comes to you know milk toast
what fence sitter fence sitter yeah
because i often don't take very strong
opinions on a lot of
political issues because it takes a lot
of research and a lot of confidence to
assert something to be true
we must have universal healthcare and
ban all private uh you know health
insurance i think is a ridiculous
position because it's too absolute but
the things i do know that make sense i
am very very
uh assertive when it comes to these
things and arrogant so when someone
comes out
when every single person when it could
be literally ever in the world comes out
and says
no we refuse i'll just say i don't care
you are wrong
period when they call when all these
when all these socialists and communists
call for centralized economics
i just say that has never worked it will
not work
we can look to computing to see why a
decentralized network works better than
a centralized one
you are just wrong in on so many levels
i will never back down from that
position listen
unless of course like new information
the two hardest moments of my life or
one
two of them were number one my wikipedia
page when i got started
it was very emotional for me i couldn't
change it it was all
lies and everyone i knew in my life was
like wow is that really true did you
really do that it was all fake
nonsense i remember this is like 10
years ago a moment of vulnerability
i was tearing up looking at my own
wikipedia page there's nothing i can do
about it
and i remember how how painful it was
to be thought ill of by a website that
was the first thing
that showed up when you googled my name
it was
painful number two a federal judge
destroying my videotape in louisiana and
nobody cared
a federal judge destroyed the evidence
that would exculpate me
in new orleans and and and everyone in
the media said
good off with his head like uh
the french revolution off with his head
dave weigel laughing
laughing that they had incarcerated a
reporter and destroyed federal evidence
and again two this was the second
hardest moment of my life and i thought
how can reporters how can news media
think it's a good thing to jail
journalists simply because they don't
like me
these these two moments of pain were for
me the hardest things to endure
and and it was i mean it was it was pain
probably
probably beyond physical pain
because it was a form of injustice and
as a martin luther king
would say you know even a small justice
a threat to justice anywhere
and for someone who's motivated by
justice to endure that type of justice
was a pain that was almost too much for
me to bear do you okay
do you believe or feel that there's a
higher like a greater
force i think there's something wrong
with me i think there's something wrong
with my brain
where i i i'm probably not thinking
about or motivated by the same sorts of
incentives
and i think the team i have there's also
like the guy who climbs up
yosemite without a harness they did an
mri scan he just isn't afraid of falling
i
i don't know i don't know what it is
alex
alex hummel i i think our our people are
so
focused on truth that they're not
worried about these other things but i
can tell you
i think this is very important having
endured a federal judge destroyed my
tape and nobody cared nobody gave a damn
that was the hardest thing i've ever
been through
and i almost wasn't strong enough to get
through it i almost i almost i told my
mom and dad i'm like i don't know if i
can get through this
why continue what happened let me let me
let me let me let me it's a long story i
wrote a book about it
so so you had a normal breakthrough you
you had an uh
i i guess uh presumably a normal
upbringing when you were a kid i would
say
i would say very very not normal
not normal but good upbringing did your
parents helicopter over you or snow plow
things away from you or did you just go
out and do your thing when you were
young
very independent hard-working father and
grandfather did a lot of
manual labor with my father and
grandfather so i i there are a couple
things in my life that i credit
my uh probably tenacity and arrogance to
and
confidence not trying to be too
self-deprecating is that my family
started a business when i was like nine
years old
and i had to go from the south side of
chicago to the north side of chicago as
a nine-year-old by myself
and so this is from the orange line to
the i guess you could take the orange
line to the to the red line or blue line
up to wrigley field and that was for
almost two years and i was entirely on
my own i had to figure things out on my
own i'd ask people for help when i
needed help
but then there was another point in my
life where i was homeless and actually i
was almost couple times
and so for me i'm kind of like there is
nothing you can take from me that has me
worried
there is nothing you can accuse me of
literally nothing because i've slept on
park benches sure like nothing left to
lose
i i as far as i'm concerned i would be
happy
sleeping in a mud hut in the middle of
the woods because it's freedom
man all that stress removed all i got to
do is figure out how many rabbits i can
eat before i die of rabbit starvation
i've got to find some fat some
vegetables that you acknowledge your
arrogance makes
is a sign of humility and being humble
and being
humiliated is important to describe an
ego booster
and once you've had your ego comple i've
had it destroyed so many times in my
life
i mean i i once you get you're right ian
once you get the ego destroyed
a few times have any of these reporters
ever had their ego destroyed
they're nothing but ego have they ever
had to were they ever locked out you
know what i mean it's like
a lot of these kids a lot of these
people i say kids probably when they
were kids
were bullied and they wanted to find
that source of power to oppress others
to get that feeling back
it's a lot of what you see in adults who
are oppressive and arrogant
and nasty to other people it's because
it's kind of a revenge for them
like i said they want to be the one
doing the hazing not the one getting
hazed right you know what it was for me
i'll let you guys do the hazing and
whatever i'll be over there by myself
don't come near me that's how i've
always when you're accused of a felony
you have not committed and had
arrested by the fbi put in shackles
thrown in federal prison
it is amazingly humbling
and of course your and i said this story
their first temptation is to talk
if you're if you let's say the feds
arrest you tomorrow and just made up
some [ __ ]
totally false the first thing you would
think psychologically is and everyone
thinks oh i'm smart enough
i would miranda writes no no my friend
when you're shackled at 24 years old
you're pissing your pants
you don't think rationally when you're
in not handcuffs but shackles
i talked to the fbi because i didn't
know any better i thought no i didn't do
it
and then they use every word against you
because that's what they do but
it's it humbles you and you think
okay now i know the level i'm playing at
it's not that they
will use everything you say against you
it's that they can say whatever they
want after you've talked
so that's right that's what i meant to
say there's a very famous
uh i think it was a supreme court
justice or a lawyer who wrote this like
long
you know profound statement on why you
never talked to law enforcement no
matter what
i saw that not even not even beat cops
and they said it's because
the moment you open your mouth that law
enforcement officer can say in a court
of law
james o'keefe admitted to everything
that's exactly what happened you'll say
that's not true i never said that well
he he certainly did
and then the the prosecutors say were
you talking with the officer yes i was
and you had a long time
of truth part of disinformation you
admitted you were there that day
it's like talking to the officers well
there's a reason for the fbi
there's a reason the fbi writes their
transcript and pencil
uh i'm serious i'm sorry i was i was
actually interviewed by the fbi too i
was arrested a number of times
for crimes i never committed and your
first instinct is like hey i didn't do
it i didn't what are you guys doing i'm
innocent i'm innocent
and then you learn like it doesn't
matter they're punishing you because of
your political stance and being
being through the ringer it definitely
wakens you up and i totally understand
this kind of sacrificial feeling as well
and and it's important to have and i
also question why don't other people
have this
too because one thing you mentioned is
this this
moment at the end of your life that
you're going to be looking back on
uh it's going to be a very important
moment it's going to be the key
instrumental moment of your life are you
going to have any regrets
are you going to be happy the way you
lived your life without any regrets and
to me i'm going 100 miles an hour as
well
and i'm happy there's other individuals
like yourself who are doing it as well
and maybe
maybe we can inspire other people to do
the same you will
yeah let's uh let's read some more of
these super chats we got dan carmo says
love the show mate james o'keefe is a
bloody worldwide hero and make no
mistakes in your tim cast
keep speaking truth like you do and you
my friend slot right into the same
category peace out legends
oh thank you very much see a lot a lot
of people
any questions given that hope you know
what i mean well questions are hard to
find because i have to go through them
and you know a lot of statements
a lot of statements and so typically i'm
like i'm reading through and there's a
lot of stuff where people are saying you
know really nice things
we have uh lawrence van daan says james
i can all but guarantee that robert
barnes and viva frey would team up with
you on
the people's defamation defense fund
their lawyers who are amazing to listen
to on youtube
barnes is a lawyer for the john doe
covington kids defamation
ah i mean i'm i love this idea luke and
tim
uh people's defamation fund
when we get not if but when we get money
from the lawsuits we'll start it
and i think you do have to be willing to
be defamed and arrested that's sort of
that's the question here's the real
question if telling the truth
and being a good investigative reporter
that 50 years ago would have won you a
pulitzer now gets you
defamed and arrested would you do it yes
or no binary question yes or no
if you actually were honest with me
about this
the majority of people would say no i'm
not willing i have a family
you know and wait wait wait wait wait i
want to go to los
washington because he was willing to
subvert and lie
to accomplish his goals he wasn't an
overt truth-teller
maybe until he became president and then
he decided to change but
so there is a willingness to not speak
the truth when that
will benefit you that is uh the essence
of the united states
okay i get it to be smart with when you
speak doesn't mean
and i've also found that being honest
doesn't mean that you always say
everything on your mind
there's a time and a place discretion
yeah discretion
i understand maybe maybe in that sense
washington and lincoln were politicians
and how they
how they did what they did but i'm
saying something a little different
which was
if it was required for you to be
arrested
and or defamed by everyone you wanted to
be liked by
would you tell the truth yes or no and i
think the majority of people would not
i would well so uh we have a lot of
people asking the same question so i
think we'll get someone out of the way
what are the people standing behind ian
with cameras what up homies
oh my goodness you guys are in frame
that's that's the that's the geek squad
from bespoke introduce yourselves
well james james shut the show off so he
picked them up
they don't have to give out their names
or anything like that if they're
anonymous they should know there's a
camera
pointed right pointed right at them just
just a heads up
can you introduce the team these are
some of my project veritas colleagues
eric spracklin chief of staff coms
mario works on our coms team we got a
couple uh project veritas uh
videographers with us here
we were coming from another assignment
and then tomorrow headed to
yet another assignment very cool nice to
meet you guys
what up guys
all right i am just uh looking through
to try and find some uh
all right let's see i think i know the
answer to this question but well
someone's asking so gorbafan
a gore before don says would project
veritas consider branching into
entertainment
the truth is needed on those fronts as
well well we'd be interested in exposing
corruption in entertainment uh
particularly in california we have a few
big sources right now in that community
in los angeles and hollywood veritas
tips at protonmail.com
listen it's a target rich environment
there's no
i'll never be out of work that's for
damn sure there's way too much going on
and um that's why we need insiders and
whistleblowers i want to record a song
and i we we've talked about this for
months and i feel like six months can
slip by if we don't just
you and i recorded something done we'll
schedule it yes well so so we're
actually we're actually working on a
song but did you guys want to do
something
about the like political messaging it
doesn't have to be not just fun
as long as the song is awesome yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna we're gonna record uh
james
what we were jamming before i in a
different life i would have been a
thespian or a musician i i i loved that
and dj and i'm getting better at that i
started as an amateur but uh
yes we will make a song what's next
three-part
question oh man jumping around i finally
found a question and then super chat
jumps because when they load away
well um let's see do we have any
questions
i'm not sure if it's a question but uh
well here we go woodworker anand says mr
o'keefe their reputation is worse than
death their legacy is at stake
if they make a stand and fail they are a
ish stain on the back on the back page
of a history book they no longer work
for us
they want to be a kennedy is that a song
reference or something i'm not sure what
that
that's sort of cryptic like a poem i
think what they're trying to say is that
many of these people just want their
name to be favorable in the history
books
the people that are the problems
politicians media establishments
that's that goes back to my uh that goes
back to my statement that
if doing the right thing required for a
temporary amount of time maybe even
some of your life being thought ill of
and defamed by all the people you want
to be liked by the
the most prescient statement i've ever
heard on the topic was by rush limbaugh
who once told me and i think he said
this publicly but he also told me
one to one was james the hardest thing
to accept about my life
is being hated by all the people
that i wanted to be liked by yeah and
and that and it sounds like a cliche of
course yes of course but no no that's
actually the hardest part about this job
for me
and i'm being honest you know my
wikipedia page
is awful and everyone i go speak to the
one of the first thing god your
wikipedia page is yeah but i mean it's
awful you realize it's because you're
not playing the game
the same way they are but but let's just
pause and think about that for a minute
because it sounds like a cliche of
course they're gonna no no no
this is really hard thing to
psychologically accept
and and i don't care who you are if
you're a human
it's no fun to be to be [ __ ] on
by everyone cnn the new york times which
i mean they just
yet sunday criticizing
and and it's almost become a cliche well
of course no not of course this is a
hard thing to accept
and it's a hard thing to endure and it's
a bitter pill
that most humans cannot swallow because
you want to be liked
nobody likes to be hated i'm not a
masochist
i'm not a sadist i didn't get into this
to be
hated [ __ ] on defamed jailed
sued lied about okay
you had to be sick in the head if you do
this to get that flack
you know what i'm trying to tell you is
that that is a necessary byproduct
of being effective one of my one of my
early mentors said
when i was in when we were enduring this
i said james it's a sign of
respect for them to do that to you
and we have to change people's
methodology in this country
they're afraid of us cnn is afraid of us
twitter is afraid of us google is afraid
of us
pinterest is afraid of us because of
these brave heroes
russell strasser the the deep state
federal agent that
we recorded the deep state agent
interrogating richard
and we put russell strash's face in the
youtube video
russell strasser is currently in hiding
because he knows we're going to door
stop them
okay you know you know what's what's
what's funny though is i haven't had
that experience where maybe it's going
to mild to spencer i guess whatever
i haven't had the people well actually
only slow down there's not a whole lot
of people have ever wanted
the respective you know a lot of people
i play music they say who's your fa who
do you look up to in music i'm like oh
look at that look up to anybody
i think they're all bad i think i have
to make music
it's always been very like you know
arrogant i guess skateboarding who is
your favorite skateboarder
but you know what's interesting for me
is something changed with the internet
and the ability for people to
investigate on their own and build their
own communities
i've actually had there are some pro
skateboarders that i grew up
watching all their videos the legends
message me on instagram and twitter
being like dude you're the best and i'm
like
whoa to have like this dude when i was
like 14
watching his video my friend's basement
on vhs being like man i wish i was as
good at skateboarding as that guy
now he's mentioning me being like dude
you're one of the best people covering
news and talking about it where i'm so
grateful i'm like
that's awesome when your heroes become
your rivals i want to tell
you a one or two minute story about dean
beckey executive out of the new york
times i was at a conference duquesne
university two and a half years ago
giving a speech
and um they invited me to my shock and i
walked up to dean beckey and i tried to
shake his hand this is the head of the
new york times
and i i've ambushed him a few times but
you know we're at this conference and i
thought maybe we could have a small talk
hey dean how you doing
he literally turned his back to me and
coward
like like a little coward and he and he
pretended like i wasn't there and he
said please go away
and at that moment there was still like
four percent of me that cared
about what the new york times thinks of
me but that just
vanished the moment you stop caring
about what they think of you is the
moment you're finally free
and we say okay that's easy to do but
it's not
the moment you stop caring about what
the new york times thinks of you
and they and and you know what most
people in the conservative movement care
so much about their twitter accounts
if you start if i said well and and
they lie about it tim they say they
don't but they do
oh yeah and the moment you stop caring
about what jack dorsey thinks about you
is the moment you're free
it's it's the conservatives for the most
part are trying to
it's like that nerdy kid who's trying to
desperately make the cool kids think
they're cool
and it's kind of sad you just got to
stop doing it you just got to be
yourself send out what you believe in
and there are a lot of prominent
conservatives who do this and just say
whatever man i don't care shut up and
they're really funny about it a lot of
these
trolls who just you know they just roll
with it i love it
but then there are some people who a lot
of these mainstream high profile
personalities
they want hollywood to like them they
want the networks to like them
and it's like but they hate you no
matter what they're not going to book
you you can
you can pretend to support them this is
the problem because when something like
the covington kids happen
how many conservatives immediately just
agreed with the narrative that it
emerged about these kids that was
not true and then changed their story
once the washington post and cnn
gave them permission to do so there were
there were a few people credited with
uh initially rejecting the narrative
outright the first was robbie sawave
and then i'm assuming you know some
people have said i was also one of the
very early on i did a video
the next day being like what is this
this is wrong because when
someone sends me a video and it's just a
kid smiling in front of a guy playing a
drum
and they tell me to be angry i'm like
for what i'm not assuming anything i
have no idea what this is
so i looked for a video and i watched it
then i found a longer video of
of the native american guy walking up to
the kids and i'm like i have no idea
what's happening why is everybody angry
so philip defranco was angry i'm like
what's he mad about what's happening
and then i made a video like these
people are nuts and then a bunch of
people actually got on board
helped source a two-hour long live
stream which i downloaded
and then showed clips where i'm like
dude these kids didn't do anything wrong
but so many people were just desperate
to fit in the same thing is true with
some of these you know
these more tragic incidents related to
black lives matter protests
before the full story comes out it's
happened several times people just jump
the gun and make assumptions
based on the leftist narrative or how
about something i i walked right into
and fell for
believing the new york times narrative
on the officer at the capitol
and how he died and it turns out it was
an unrelated stroke
and i believed it i just believed the
new york times said i i
sh you know what it's because who to a
certain degree
you do still trust big major news unless
they show me primary sources and they
should write raw they have
that all credibility i don't believe
them i don't believe you
unless you show me your source material
they have given us no reason to trust
them
and and i think this what we're talking
about right now is the real issue tim
it's
it's the perverse incentive for people
that supposedly fight for truth to sell
out
in order to get positive ink by all the
people they want to be liked by
the moment you don't care is the moment
you're free we do have several ladies
asking if james is single
what's the verdict veritas tips at
protonmail.com
that's v-e-r-e that's right 1-877 cars
for kids
you ever heard that yeah yeah yeah
veritas tips at protonmail
it's v-e-r-i-t-a-s-t are you giving that
out now for the single ladies
at protonmail.com it's a one-stop shop
everyone
you can you can be a whistleblower you
can donate
i mean there's a lot of things you can
do just sign up here here's a real
question though uh kimchi 93 says james
do you ever get nervous confronting
people oh yeah
no no did you used to no uh
the what's the guy the climber that
climbs you know alexander
the guy that was a great documentary he
climbs the yosemite in california
without a harness
and they had to scan his brain for fear
i don't get scared
at all doing this i'm trying to think
about i'm definitely
sometimes i'm not afraid confronting the
people
um what am i afraid there's a part of me
that is afraid of the legal threats like
going to jail
sucked um but i you know you choose to
overcome your fear and
and you you do the right thing to
despite your fear
luke has absolutely gone after hundreds
of high profile people as well so i'll
throw it to you as well
it's it's fun it's exciting uh there is
a little bit of nervousness but once
you're doing it you're kind of in this
flow state
and when you're locking eyes with like a
lord jacob rothschild or a henry
kissinger or as binya brzezinski or bill
clinton or tony blair
how much time we got here when you're
locking eyes with them you're in the
moment and
it feels amazing and incredible to be
able to to get
rid of this facade of them getting their
their butts kissed all the time
and just slap them with reality and
they're shocked and they quiver you mean
the confrontation yeah the confrontation
and the way they react it's
so telling because they they're so
cowardly they expect you to kiss their
ass
and then once you're like let's talk
about this and this and this
real issue what i'm worried about is
when i do it like two examples when i
called into jeff zucker's conference
line in december this like
i dialed into the ceo of cnn's 9 a.m
conference call
my concern is not fear it's like i only
have one take
like i can't do this more than yeah i
have one one
shot at this don't mess up i just okay
when do i interject and say hello jeff
this is james
what's the moment in the dialogue and
then when i was in the acorn thing as
the pimp
the whole i'm not afraid i'm like
looking this is like when the hidden
cameras are like this big and they're
strapped to your chest like with velcro
i remember those so i'm looking in my
pocket like is this still
filming oh the battery's dying
so my uh the the producer in me is just
technically worried is the camera
filming like logistics do we have the
audio
i'm always just worried about the little
things yeah yeah and they go wrong a lot
i confronted john bolton i asked him uh
you know if
my my friend's drawing a portrait of him
does he want the blood on his hands on
the left hand so his right hand
he freaked out and and and i remember
being so happy and giddy because it was
a real interview and at the end i just
hit him with that
and and there's no audio of it no no
at all my team will always tell me it's
always the little things like do we have
backup
audio the worst thing about in this
business is when you do the thing
and the camera failed or the battery's
done yeah so it happens
i'm so worried then scared we have
another question from
palm thumb james have you ever
considered branch offices in other
countries
i.e canada yes yeah we got a lot of
messages from canada
from europe there are laws you know luke
and i have been to greece
yeah we got tear gas together we got
tear gas athens in 2015. yeah
um veritas is going global we got
whistleblowers all over the world there
are certain laws we can't break but
we're protected by the united states
supreme court bart nikki case
2001 a whistleblower uh uh can
themselves
uh send us a recording even if they
potentially violated an nda or broke the
law so we will branch out we are
branching out we're going global
right on well i think uh we've gone a
little bit over but uh we'll
we'll sort of wrap up this portion of
the show here and i if you want to stick
around and do a members segment we'll
talk about this
that sounds great right on well for
those that are listening smash that like
button on your way out make sure you go
to timcast.com
become a member because we're going to
continue the conversation in a
mostly uncensored manner i say mostly
because we still have some you know
general
like there are families who listen so we
try to keep things but we swear a whole
lot
we'll we'll speak about things that
typically youtube won't let us go to
timcast.com that should be up
maybe about an hour so don't forget to
again like subscribe hit the
notification bell
leave us a good comment you can follow
me on parlor or mines at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.com timcast and
youtube.comcastnews this show
is live monday to friday at 8pm james do
you want to shout out anything else
before we wrap this portion up the only
thing i would shout out
is if you're watching this and you work
for a silicon valley tech
giant or the government or you see fraud
happening in your municipality
corporation or government bureau contact
us
on the inside veritas tips at
protonmail.com
right on i think the shirt i'm wearing
is very fitting for today's discussion
it says practice media distancing and
you yourself could exclusively get this
shirt by going to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com if you want
to see
the former head of the cia scorm and
sweat balls after
asking him some serious questions you
can on my youtube channel we
are change and james you brought up a
very important point when i asked you
about alternative social media platforms
you brought up email lists
those are key because you actually have
the list
you actually have contact with your
members no one's standing in the way
i've been building mine up we are
change.org top right hand corner it
means a lot to me thank you james for
coming on and thanks for having me
i also want to shout out this shirt that
you can get on the timkats.com store i
think it is
uh harumf um james one time tim and i
went to
your office and met with some of the
reporters they asked me what can we do
what's the best thing we can expose and
at the time i didn't have an answer but
i've thought about it and i'm hoping
that
at some point someone can get inside the
federal reserve and break the books on
that
company because the government's not
allowed to um
to audit them at present and i find that
despicable that's the whole so if your
fail
if you're out there listening that's my
advice um and check out ian
crossland.net new and improved you can
get one of these free the code mugs
if you really believe in free software
and breaking up this monopoly
of uh internet sensory [ __ ] love it love
you man
and then me pushing all the buttons for
these wild guys i'm sour patch lids on
twitter i
am also on mines i'm on
gab as real sour patch lids and i'm also
on instagram's real sour patch lids
we're going to be jumping over to
timcast.com for the exclusive members
only portion of the show but for
everybody that hung out uh thus far and
super chat ed
seriously thank you guys so much make
make this all possible
and i really do appreciate it so again
smash that like button and we will see
you all in about an hour or so or
whenever you come by timcast.com bye
guys
you